the way you started
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool breads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
haha i always thought that a press like
me could squeeze and hold it in my
cheeks like a turtle pink we please the
masses but clenching it in our ass is
tijuana mexico holy nick to tokyo people
know me though i swear my cheeks always
work it's like i'm bout to give birth
unexpected fun oh you heard kamala heard
she said it smelled like that crap i
tried to blame the dog but it was on its
way out
i didn't know what i was trying to say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
knife
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
that's called i'm still in shock from
the intro
wow i mean it works yeah hit song
yeah
we're still on the youtube right we are
still on we are still on
today or now top 40 shits
casey kasem golden shits this one comes
in from a request from alan schenectady
who has his lover across those cold
trucking nights poop featuring joe biden
all right
this is joe requesting
anything
his mind is gone hell actually he's
confused what is he i have no idea all
right look uh we are starting late today
why because bring it on up in a little
quadrant there quarter black garrett we
are covering the written house of i
guess live stream right now we've been
covering it since the beginning seems
like people have caught on now and
everyone else has been talking about it
oh it's weird we've been talking about
this from the get-go i think that your
right to self-defense is on trial right
now let me be really clear about this
i actually am really concerned
that
they're going to do their closing
arguments today they're going to present
them i'm concerned that
this is too much of a layup case in
other words they're saying well wait he
came up and he aimed his gun at you i
really don't think that we want to set
the precedent
of
having to scream friendly friendly
friendly while people are throwing gas
bombs and buildings running as far away
as you can until you run into a
barricade turn around see a shirtless
pedophile telling you that he's going to
kill you hear a gunshot in order for you
to defend your life i think that at the
very first moment said someone i'm going
to kill you click bang in other words
lunges at you i do i i am of the
personal belief that if someone throws a
gas bomb a molotov cocktail into your
place
of residence or your place of work that
they forfeit the right to live not
saying they deserve to be executed
that's not what i'm saying but i'm
saying the second someone puts you in a
situation where you could
potentially even
leave without your life they forfeit the
right to live and i want a justice
system that reflects that yeah people
say what would america look like if we
had a bunch of call ridden houses um an
improvement
safer wait do you mean somebody trying
to help people and protect the community
that is father and multiple relatives we
can't have kids washing off graffiti i
know going out with first aid kits kids
he's a white supremacist that shoots
white people yeah well he makes this
self-love he shot the only man who was
screaming the n-word at the time
david's a deep fake oh so we have a lot
to get to today we're going to present
to you kind of a highlight of what has
taken place and also set some context
before we go to the closing arguments we
will watch it with you we'll try and
balance hearing what they have to say
and then of course a lot of breaks
filling in that sort of uh empty time um
but first gerald a is here how are you i
am well sir how are you dave i'm doing
okay yeah i'm a little still in my head
i'm a little heavy you're a little heavy
i was telling people i weighed in i had
to do blood work last week tell me tell
me why tell the people well no no no no
no no let me introduce everybody okay
and i'll go back and say quarter black
garrett how are you good morning good
morning i don't i don't weigh 10 more
pounds no you don't no now you just
come on you just gave away the punch
line well
that's what i do and it wasn't ten it's
nine and a half you went over
oh he's out like a baby
you don't know plinko rules i don't know
what it's like with your steve harvey
game shows and dave landau the family is
going to be in naples florida uh this is
a comedy club how are you sir good ahoy
good good i'm doing good yeah come out
to the show this weekend and let me let
you you guys know we're starting late
today naples florida for dave we're
starting late today because we wanted to
make sure that we didn't waste too much
time before getting the closing
arguments if you ever try and tune in
for example we didn't do a show on
thursday we let everyone know on all of
our platforms if we haven't specifically
let you know the show is still happening
it just may not stream on youtube we get
suspended all the time so 10 a.m eastern
monday through thursday you can go to
rumble or you can join mug club where
you get an extra 45 minutes to two hours
of show like last week on the truck yeah
and make sure if we ever get cut off
right in the middle of a show i mean
youtube would never do that it would
never be that it's never happened what
happens it's still on rumble because
rumble actually wouldn't ever do that no
they actually would not ever do that uh
so i did i what happened is i was doing
blood work on friday and i weighed 229.
okay and then uh uh this morning i
weighed 238.5 now i was
tracking my brain what could it be and
then i thought
well yesterday i did order barbecue i
ordered a half pound of okay burnt burnt
get your calculators out i ordered a
half pound of sausage and a full rack of
ribs it goes by rack i don't know how
heavy that is but that's all i ate i
didn't eat anything else because i was
so full so you ate copious amounts of
beef or beef like products i forgot to
mention that you did that four or five
days before that as well well you know
well you got to establish a pattern it
takes ribs though or beef ribs i do i'm
not a scientist well that's true i don't
know why on a doctor it's not like they
can give you that information
beyond ribs beyond self-respect is where
i found myself with
barbecue sauce on my man tits and my
scars
and i'm proud to be an american
where at least
[Applause]
do you have any sides no no no just the
all the meat no i'm not a [ __ ]
hey you're walking down the sides there
what is this come on sweet potatoes okay
cheese yeah well i get it you're trying
to score points with quarter black
garrett what's next collard greens mr
detroit oh yeah you're right i've had
collard greens thank you yeah well
they're terrible i used to think colored
greens you're terrible then i found out
that it was just like saying it right
yeah it's basically yeah well except
there's more flavor to it it's green
yeah yeah black people cooking salt
sodium that makes everything better so i
think i'm just retaining so anyway
before we so before we have a lot to get
to as far as what happened with the
trail before we get the closing
statements you guys will let me know uh
as the closing statements come up before
any of that um there was a sketch on snl
do they still call it regarding joe
rogan i gotta tell you you can see their
budget is it has been depleted because
they used to have great wardrobe and
makeup and
uh
i just want to objectively
offer you this sketch because i know a
lot of you aren't really watching it
nowadays unless youtube pays to thrust
it in front of you right yeah as a
glorified ad it shows again why it's one
of the least relevant shows in
television here is a sketch with a woman
playing ted cruz big bird and uh pete
davidson is joe rogan
well that's right
i use the whole sphere factor and now
doctors fear me
can you help me joke oh sure thing big
bird you see i took carlos mencia down i
can take coven
here's some zinc
an ayahuasca
and some horse medicine well why would a
bird take horse medicine i'm a human and
i took horse medicine
and i'm speaking of things that uh are
horse-like
uh today's two sponsors are the letters
s and d as in i can s my own d
do they not even have to try an
impression i don't understand
it's very
well
they never looked like they were reading
before right they look like the last two
years this was just staring at a cue
card like s and i can s my own d i i've
never even i've never done a joe rogan
impression i guarantee you i could go in
and do it better you just if you're
gonna do jerome you have to talk about
that's crazy that's it coming why that's
crazy that's insane right it's
ridiculous that's just say some stuff
like that yeah oh i'm joe rogan i can
ask my own d that sounds nothing like
him he looks more like bill burr he does
in his third right spot by the letter by
the letter q right you know
big bird over here if we get it that
he's trying to uh you know trying to
nest and [ __ ]
i mean don't you exaggerate the stuff
about the character like isn't that how
you do an impression you exaggerate the
most obvious thing i just not just
saying they're reading a cue card why
don't they have a sleeve of tattoos
why didn't they just use his sleeve of
tattoos yes that's true exactly oh that
was that's what passes for comedy now
well it's just it really is clapter why
was big bird that tall
it's big bird it's not it's not it's not
sure
why and why don't they just get an
actual big bird yeah they can just go
down to go down the hall
i think big bird's been on the show
there's probably a costume somewhere
yeah i think it's in their contract well
well he can't well we can't now either
but who wrote that the ivor mexican
thing is like months old i know it's
like
you know what's hot
yeah i have a mechanic
that's what's happening right now well
that's what happens when you get rid of
the youtube dislike feature
they have no idea what's current exactly
nobody will ever know what's good or i
mean it's funny if he comes in like
squirting the horse paste on the bird or
something like that it's like wow you're
disgusting do you hear this sick
i mean
it's horsty why is gerald so filthy
everything is bird porn with him no no i
didn't mean it like that you guys took
it there that's just you should have
seen him during the bp oil spill
watching those dawn commercials he loved
it he's like
somebody's a dirty bird
oh jesus just clean it up with the
rubber gloves spraying soap all over it
but not cleaning it
[Music]
is that is that a thing i don't know
so those are my questions look if you
guys comment below let me know uh
especially if you're watching this on
archive what do you think the outcome is
going to be the cal written house trial
uh it obviously should be
acquitted on all charges yes well now
they just they just you just said they
just acquitted what they just did
oh god sorry just dismiss the underage
gun charge that's it it's over yeah
it's over
kyle i hope you get i hope you get your
uh
your malicious shoes ready for a sequel
you're going dancing he's not even in a
militia he's just a kid he's a lifeguard
trying to protect us i don't know what
they if they can't get him on that which
is the law was written to be murky yeah
then they certainly can't get him on the
self-defense issue oh gosh no i really
don't understand why it's still about
race everything i see
yeah but he's so good that's a dumb
argument yeah
i know no no it doesn't matter who he
again look if you could call black
people running for office the black face
of white supremacy you can certainly say
a white kid was a white supremacist even
though he still shot white people he's a
self self-loathing white supremacist
at the black man running for office
dressed as a gorilla
right now right not be racist and you
can cancel one of the best black
comedians slash yes of course this is
the bizarro world that we live in now
yeah we have dave chappelle coming to
our school let's protest it not have him
wow that's that's what never leave your
lips oh well you know how about how
about he does his event and you all go
into the bathroom with men and see how
that one painted
so all right let's go really quickly to
uh a couple of things before this before
this comes up here this stream and we'll
go we'll go to the closing arguments um
uh you know we don't need to hit this i
don't think we need to hit the oh wait i
was so excited what you want to hit this
all right remember remember the
impeachment trial when chuck schumer had
a friday and slip it's not the first
time this happened then we just had
shift do it again on uh
it's childish and then again we're
easing into the show
here's a flashback there will be a trial
and when that trial ends senators will
have to decide
if they believe donald john donald john
trump
incited the erection
insurrection
against the united states
guilty
podium starts rising it's uh it's the
ghost of the house
he's walking out hiding it with a
leather book yeah yeah he brings that
podium everywhere i don't know if he
knew that
sir your time is expired please uh leave
the the bell rings they discharge them
for lunch he's like you go i'll call me
i'll let you go
give me five minutes he's just walking
out covering with a trapper keeper yes
yeah every teenager in high school knows
you've set in that desk longer than you
needed to so adam schiff had a similar
mishap here
on the view not saying what he's saying
is what he meant to say
let's not use that as a smoke screen
to somehow shield donald trump's
culpability
for inviting russia to help them in the
election which they did
for trying to coerce ukraine into
helping him in the next election
which he did uh into inciting an
erection insurrection which he did
none of that is
diminished by the fact that people lied
to christopher steele no i think just
your credibility is
ah
yeah ouch
brain is just an autocorrect for a
perverts phone
it's funny because this is worse he's
looking at a woman and saying it it's
like did you with this big fishy bug
eyes checking her out yeah
yeah i mean
insurrection are you in for some
inciting later is that a mirror you know
what that means inside
he excited point as i'm hard as a
houndstooth cats couldn't scratch it
that's right donald trump does the
chubby all right i'm going to sit here
cross-legged for five minutes after the
show yes
so here let's move on to this uh really
quickly this is uh you all have heard of
uh of joe biden um of course he's a big
fan big fan of the negro league i think
i found out because the negro leagues
and the great negro big fan of the hard
r's yes the hard hours hard hours hard
as a negro
league it's almost two hours in a negro
uh he said it uh so a lot of people
don't know this was a momentous day last
thursday november 11th
so actually when we're talking about the
great the great negro league so it's
actually time for a new installment of
today in history
[Music]
november 11th 1918 world war one finally
comes to an end after four long years of
gruesome battle an armistice was finally
signed between germany and the allies
ending one of the bloodiest wars ever
witnessed by the world stage
then november 11 2021
former vice president joseph biden said
this you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson his name was satchel page
in history
[Music]
hey by the way really quickly snopes and
media i tried to cover for biden saying
no media i'd actually said no he didn't
say great negro yes he did and we saw it
said it like four times in a row yeah
and snow's tried to cover saying based
on the context of his remarks it appears
that biden was going to describe paige
as the great pitcher in the negro
leagues but the words that came out of
his mouth were i've adopted the attitude
of the great negro at the time pitcher
and the negro leagues went on to become
look uh we don't care you claimed that
the base judge in the rittenhouse trial
was racist yeah and i do mean this by
the way when you're talking about who
was a snopes and media because he said i
hope our hope our asian food isn't uh
isn't uh you know uh delayed there at
one of those cargo ships in long beach
i said they thought that was racist
negro i don't think any of it is racist
to be fair i think joe biden's a racist
in the way that all democrats are racist
and white supreme complex they think
that black people are inferior and need
white democrats to save them i don't
think he meant anything by it however by
the standards and i have them written
here yeah we need we need to cancel
former vice president joe biden well
yeah he's telling the last president uh
every word he said was a racist dog
whistle this is a rape whistle yes quite
loud it's a rape whistle that actually
just calls more rapists that's true oh
my god they're descending upon me yeah i
don't think he's racist either i just
think he has you know pudding left in
his brain yes yeah and he's like
the league
i don't know i don't know what that is
he was a pitcher jackie robinson was
there isn't this the whole point though
like so media let's let's make the case
and i understand okay the great negro
league pitcher satchel page and you stop
yourself it was a league it's it's a
really really bad place to stop yourself
yeah if that's true you're like the
great negro this is a good time to pause
pause move on the only way it comes
if he was sneezing mid-negro the great
no [ __ ]
leagues you know that you'd be like oh
thank god he could have broken that in
song like
[Laughter]
i heard something about the romance
languages
well it ain't over until the demented
old circus monkey sings that's true so
uh by the way uh i'm talking about joe
biden the dimensional character
okay
joe biden is a demented old circus
monkey yeah
no someone going to try and say that's
racial can i not refer to the former
vice president who's beyond white
yes i mean he's so white he should be
walking through walls and [ __ ]
and they're going to say it's racist to
refer to him as a demented old circus
monkey he's like
yeah there is a chance he's just a ghost
like if you found that out you go i'm
not surprised i'm not surprised i had a
feeling he was totally would have cast
him is that at night he puts on a blue
dress and shakes the floorboards walks
down the stairs like it's a girl in blue
dress like it's just not it's just joey
it's just joe yeah joe again carefully
now
he dropped some n-bombs too it's we've
been telling him not to but you know we
make some we clean up on the haunted
house tours he's a civil war reenactor
yes he also leaves a brown trail yeah
it's easy to track him down by the way
he leaves ectoplasm everywhere
especially his pants
[Laughter]
as we continue uh you can follow me on
instagram by the way that's the place
where we do some stuff that's not
necessarily on the show uh i guess i
don't know they call it more lifestyle
things things that you know i don't know
you get to see my ass and yoga pants
and we'll take your chat take your chat
later on as we continue on mug club okay
here is before and you guys let me know
when they're doing any closing
statements i want to set this context up
don lemon professional uh taint juice
shiver in men's face
he did it that's a that's like a listen
listen he's an artist some paint with
watercolors
pastels some rub their taint juice in
pastures dry faces mustaches yep they
call it a paccoos
your anus just so you know he did it
yeah we'll just stay clear megan kelly
on the show
what a piece of life of garbage don
lemon but here he is he wanted one of us
in i don't want to say incoherent
terrorists because i understand where
he's coming from and i'm going to play
and pause this
live for you he actually summarizes
everything that i want to say only
saying it in a way as though he's mad
about it
and this is where i talk about the great
divide in the united states we cannot
find common ground if we're saying the
same thing
and one believes that it's reprehensible
and one thinks that it's virtuous so
let's go through don lemon talking about
kyle rittenhouse and all of this stuff
between taint juice smearings
this is the ultimate entitlement
that again
you can insert yourself into a situation
with a gun that you're not supposed to
be carrying kill two people injure and
it is you are made to be a hero
by the public pause no he was actually
vilified kyle written house he was
actually vilified by the media cnn he
was vilified by the president who uh
inferred that he was a white supremacist
he was vilified by everybody he was put
uh on trial by public media we'll get to
that in a second because that gage
grosskritz has been uh changing his
story when he's appeared a little bit
cnn and good morning america that's why
the left wants to try you in the court
of public opinion because you're not
under oath so no no this is right away
this is a a false pretext that he was
made a hero no you already assumed he
was guilty just like nick sandman by the
way hope your lowered salary is worth it
continue
you
you see someone jogging down the street
he's talking about opera into your hands
you think it's you're complaining
you're not even sure if they are
committing a crime because what it is
your street it is your town it is your
country it is the ultimate
degree of entitlement when people
believe that this is how they're
supposed to be what the right is saying
about kyle rittenhouse is that well the
government didn't do its job so it took
a 17 year old kid to come in and do what
was right that's vigilantism that's not
what people are not supposed to be
vigilantes we're not supposed to be
taking um justice into our own hands
pause
wasn't there something about no justice
no peace you dumb [ __ ]
can i just be clear that no justice no
peace they just threaten the mayor of
new york if they reinstate crime units
that there will be riots and bloodshed
you supported it no justice no peace by
the way we should be agreeing that the
cops didn't do their job so it did
require i wish that it didn't require a
17 year old i wish that the cops were
doing their job but they were told to
stand down bye bye bye bye bye bye
people like you
you you supported people taking justice
into their own hands to be clear
continue imagine if every single person
in america did that imagine if you call
for um for black men or just black folks
to be armed and go out in the streets
and
you know do what they think justice take
it back remember and what they did to
you and slavery whatever go and and take
things and do imagine people were that's
exactly what happened yeah
he did he just described it imagine it's
like him saying look imagine if
and by the way totally support black
people going out and yeah being armed
and protected
i actually would like black people to
protect their neighborhoods yes i would
like to see less uh black children being
hauled out in stretchers and more gang
members in those streets being uh you
know left to die and i got her alone
removed yeah removed from society from
the streets just to be clear but it
would be like don lemon saying imagine
if black people and their supporters and
enablers at antifa and uh you know
funded leftist nonprofits imagine if
they caused four billion dollars in
damages and thousands of arrests and
hundreds of casualties and dozens of
people murdered imagine if they did that
how would you feel probably like kyle
rittenhouse yeah
probably like many many many millions of
people felt all last year yeah that's
how we would why was kyle there uh how
about you answer for your guys first by
the way yours raped five kids let's
start with that let's keep going yeah
why are you doing defending it or just
doing that well i know why would there
be a different perception in this
country about who should and who
shouldn't carry guns would our gun laws
be different i certainly think so so
there's a double standard but it is the
ultimate degree of entitlement this is
what i'm supposed to do because this
belongs to me meaning the street this
town and this country and i think it's
time meaning your house their business
but it is the absolute truth i don't
watch your street saying
this is my i pay taxes here and
therefore i no if something if i see
someone breaking the law
i call the cops all right pause that's
enough yeah really you call you wanted
to defund the police the police who you
say are corrupt and systemically racist
by the way we both agree that the cops
aren't doing their job very effectively
you don't want any police we want the
police to be able to take out violent
criminals you claim that that's racist i
don't i call the cops no you don't well
of course you do but you claim that you
hate the everything that you just said
i can i've never seen anything more
delusional and this is why i don't think
there's going to be any sort of healing
between the rightness the women who just
voted against critical race they're
trying to say there is no critical race
they're being taught and they're going
uh i've seen my kids books yeah yeah
he's saying well there is there were no
violent protests uh my business was
burnt down
you can't have healing when one side is
so far off the beam of reality and i
think that's what this this this trial
serves to highlight it's a lot more than
just a kid well he's completing a whole
lot of issues here but i i just want to
bring up the point
that's unamerican you're basically
saying that this is not our kind i'm not
saying
people us our country right we are
community
white
supposed to protect so just just for
example that's why we have weapons yeah
don lemon if i see a woman being raped
are you saying that i shouldn't go try
to stop the attacker no you got to call
the police wait 5 10 15 minutes let the
rape continue okay so if i see a kid
being abducted should i not try to
rescue that kid is that what you're
saying as well that's why there's amber
alerts hold on i want to make sure i
want to make sure that i'm not a white
supremacist trying to say this is my
street my city my country to fit don
lemon's view of the world no you want
people out there protecting their
communities yeah you're not going out
there trying to find criminals the
armada everything is a completely
separate issue those guys were idiots
we're talking about somebody going out
and saying hey don't burn this down and
if people get hurt i don't know if they
were idiots i think it was an
unfortunate situation that i think i
don't think they went out hunting no i
don't think so either i think it was one
of those situations they called the cops
you don't call the cops if you're about
to go commit a hate crime but i agree i
think uh they're still stupid well yeah
what about don lemon i mean what
entitlement when don lemon sticks his
taint in a jack lalanne juicer so he can
smear it on passersby it will at the
local bar who's more into that is a mind
the f it's not that don lemon oh that
drink a lemonhead yes
and it's sour lemon butt actually butt
it's not that he smeared his ball juice
on someone's mustache it's how many
steps
did it take to get how much of a lack of
accountability must it be in don lemon's
life to act that way in public because
he is so entitled why because he's a
black gay famous rich man who can get
away with things that nobody else can
that's the truth when he talks about
entitlement yeah yeah yeah you smearing
your bunghole juice on a part-time
bartenders or the wait staff that's far
less entitled uh i suppose than someone
who wants to protect their entire life
savings their business their livelihood
from a gas bomb admittedly from the
prosecution that's tossed in there all
right yeah nothing screams you have no
character more than the way you treat
staff and that's the worst way you could
treat somebody yeah it's about it's
upsetting for you it's worse than raping
it's just because it's just humiliating
yeah well because then everyone yeah the
guy has to answer for why you didn't
ass that's the worst most embarrassing
part i'm telling you if don lemon
the the articles that they pushed pushed
the wiener juice in the guy's mustache
so hard that the guy was pushed back it
wouldn't even be a second thought it
would create a spring back with a boom
right down the pipe
it would be like oh i'm a rubber band
now bang there you go when you rub your
taint juice in my face what is the
amazing
like was he trying to get laid i don't
understand yeah the context yeah that's
the don lemon mating call
they have it like a duck call it's going
to be the next thing the lemon dynasty
just yeah
it just squirts you i don't know what
that was i don't know how to do it i'm
just like watching
these people do mental gymnastics in the
worst way possible
and then even compare the two yeah it
just makes no it it all just makes no
sense they just want the they want
the reaction that they're going to get
yes more violence more news and i'm
going to move on here because we were
going to by the way uh jenna ellis
people who retweeted just my tweet about
cal rittenhouse it's been banned from
twitter just so you know i've been
banned from facebook it's been censored
you're not allowed to praise cal right
now so it's right to self-defense
youtube has removed the dislike button
before we talk about yeah that right
there i don't spend too much time for
retweeting me no for a meme for a kyle
written house meme well that's probably
because it was very funny i'm only like
what it is though
i'm flying blind on that one but i
assume you probably deserve it so
you would
i have no idea
i uh the dislike button gone from
youtube look this is very telling all
conservatives are upset liberals are
either silent or supported that should
tell you who wants transparency again
the most downvoted video of all time was
from youtube themselves and then i
believe rounding out the top ten like
seven of them were joe biden videos uh
so from the white house it's very clear
and all their arguments are bull crap
just they said well we believe this will
help the mental health of creators just
so you know i can tell you this as a
youtube creator i can still see dislikes
behind yes the creator so that doesn't
help because i can see him it's just not
publicly available it doesn't make any
sense whatsoever they just this is it's
very very simple i won't spend any more
time on this the reason that youtube
wants to get rid of the dislike button
the reason they are permanently getting
rid of it is because the average
american the average per the average
citizen should not be hurt
and so what happens is abc nbc cbs cnn
they pay this huge these huge sums of
cash right when we had the vox
apocalypse it wasn't about vox it was
about nbc universal we were made aware
no uncertain terms they spend a lot of
money in advertising and youtube will
side with nbc universal right and so we
were demonetized so in order to favor
these multinational corporations whose
content sucks like we just showed you
with snl they get rid of the dislike
button because on an even playing field
content like this wins they know it and
a lot of other conservative content out
there abc nbc cbs colbert biden youtube
rewind they perform like crap so it's as
simple as get rid of the dislike button
so you can't be heard ban support of
kyle rittenhouse so you can't be hurt
and then don t juice lemon has the nerve
to go up there and say he was turned
into a hero by the public really
okay yeah they want you to get their
news the news from them and them only
yeah they don't want you to hear any of
this i spent and i'm not going to stay
long on this but i spent about a minute
walking friends at a party through the
series of events and i said here's what
happened in kyle rittenhouse's trial at
the end they go holy crap i've never
heard that yeah i'm like it's probably
because they've watched that's what they
were done scratch and sniff lemonade
yeah well they're not they're concerned
no they're conservative guys they just
hadn't seen a whole lot about the trial
and i was like yeah and by the way you
start blaring back streets back on your
ghetto pretty much yeah absolutely the
only way i can be more hey who wants to
play mad gabs
sipping 40s with your friend in a
wheelchair
no i was not doing that all right they
shot ricky
this is something i don't know if you've
seen this yet dave gage gross crew
crocodile cage gage ears gauge ears guy
who decided to invest in cages in his
ears
uh he and this is why i want to be
really clear about this this is why
they want to
try you in the court of public opinion
because we saw gays cross-crews when he
was under oath
he had to answer
cal right now only shot you once you
came up on him once you
approached him once you invaded his
space and aimed your firearm at him and
he said correct to be clear
now he goes on cnn and he's gone on good
morning america with that i don't know
michael strain i guess he's kind of a
football player and what's hilarious i
recommend you go watch the entire
interview because of the selective
editing like so what happened you i
feared for my life doctors you're like
what what is that
it's so clearly edited by his lawyer but
it's way better to try you in the court
of public opinion why because you can
just lie unlike being under oath
with the threat of perjury so watch the
difference
and the media's been trying to carry the
water because they know that they're
losing end of cal written house here
watch gage gross crew it's the
difference between when he's been on the
stand
and his recent press tour there you go
so here you're allowed to say whatever
you feel like you you need to say so
you're saying that you actually did you
weren't pointing your gun at him is that
what you're saying
that's absolutely what i'm saying yes
look like right now your arm is being
shot
that looks like my
bicep being vaporized yes okay
and it's being vaporized as you're
pointing your gun directly at you
yes
yes
the only way that i could have sustained
the injury that i have
as if i had been shot
with my arms up it wasn't until you
pointed your gun at him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct well i think any time you
see your would-be murderer
it's emotional and defendant would be
murderer murdering anthony huber
the objection is sustained that whether
the death of anthony huber was caused by
murder
or not is for you jurors to decide and
not for the witness or michael strahan
or anderson cooper i get just as good oh
yeah are you just going to go on their
shows and retract everything you said
yeah because i'd have a good mind to
beat your ass and dip it in cheese hey
it's something else i'll tell you
the cheese ass it's a new thing you know
we talk about cheese head but i think uh
young gage you might have your head in
there is full of uh is full of cheese
inside there
i mean it as a pejorative you know
why why do you have here spreaders gage
yeah i don't know i don't know what lost
out to that when you were making your
piggy bank you said i want something
that's irreversible and frankly makes me
look like an [ __ ] you look like a
child star just before you see him
hanging in a closet yeah you know like
if drew barrymore didn't get her life on
track back with the coke benders yeah
more like the seaquest boy right on his
way out right or the the one boy who
didn't get felt up by michael jackson
but he got passed around like a joint by
every other hollywood producer at a
party cory haim that's the one
the point is you're an [ __ ] mr gage
are we clear on that yes that we can say
under oath say it
excuse me tell them who you are tell
them who you really are
well i was a victim no no no no no
you're under oath i'm an [ __ ] that's
right that's a good spacer head you are
the feldman of the two quarries you know
do you think i could stick like some
like some uh knitting needles in through
your giant spacers make you look like
pinhead from hellraiser i think it'd be
fitting since you're such a pinhead you
know i'm sorry heck razor purple
oh yeah oh
oh no if i keep talking like that i bet
you uh i might get food poisoning from
that asian food
[Laughter]
oh my gosh that's what they're mad at
him for for not specifying oh can we
bring can we bring that let's just bring
that up right now the montage of how
base this judges whichever clip that's
uh
uh i don't know which one it is
i think got it clip 4. all right bring
this up i've just loved this judge
chocolate syrup cassava melon and uh
a playboy model marley renfro were
enlisted to create an iconic scene in
this film
it's trivia what is
heard of it i i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that and it
gives um it's just smiling
i'll leave it at that the actions that i
had talked about
there it is
we're done in bad faith
my good faith feeling this morning after
watching that testimony was you had left
the door open a little bit now we had
something new and i was going to probe
it i don't believe you
there better not be another incident
i'll take the emotion under advisement
to the extent that
if there's no
and again
pardon me that was before that get
brazen with me
you knew very well you
know very well that an attorney can't go
into these types of areas when the judge
has already ruled without asking outside
the presence of the jury to do so so
don't give me that anything else
what time do you
uh let's hope for one o'clock i don't
know the uh hope the asian food isn't
coming it's on isn't on one of those
boats in long long beach harbor
um but let's uh
aim for one o'clock and by the way
there's some anti-asian defamation
league representatives this is deeply uh
offensive stop it there's nothing even
remotely that could be in other words if
that's offensive let's just all start
being incredibly racist again i guess
right what's the point he basically said
i hope our friend isn't on a container
rotting away yeah the joe biden jokes
yeah it's like come on i i don't
understand why
are they mad that he said that or that
he said asian food i guess
it's racist what are we supposed to say
i mean isn't it if it's asian food from
the orient yes i think that's a rug of
hell yes yeah i just i i don't uh can we
go back to gage's comment he goes the
only way physiologically or whatever he
said that i could receive the wound as
if my hands were up and i'm like
that would work gage unless we didn't
have like footage and pictures yeah you
even commenting on the footage in
pictures and i will say though it was
your hand was up the bullet moved it
that way no it was i mean like it just
it blew me and it just so happens to be
happenstance that the part of the arm
that kyle shot made it so that he
couldn't let go of the gun he's like
yeah there are cameras
like a turtle when it bites on your
finger
turned into a jim varney
and anderson cooper just guns on his
nose
anderson cooper just is like oh that's
very interesting i'm like oh my what
world are we living in where this is
this and by the way they've been saying
he's a white supremacist the judge just
to be clear it's like oh hey thanks
thanks leftist this is it's not what
they say sometimes sometimes it's what
they don't say in this case what they
don't want to say but we all know is
true is oh a patriotic song
makes you right conservative makes you
white supremacists yeah so therefore
again okay the left hates america it
couldn't be clear like rollers played at
trump rallies barracuda was played at
sarah palin rallies does that mean no
one can listen to it do you think it was
created for trump rallies or is it
because it was a top number one hit
perennial i don't know for how long and
it's a patriotic song and this guy who
is a judge who is serving his country is
probably a patriotic american you want
to say that any patriotic song is white
supremacy that's why the left wants a
different flag that's why the left wants
a different anthem they absolutely hate
the united states of america or they
would not be mad that the guy's song is
proud to be an american it would be a
non-issue if they didn't revile people
who are proud to be american are you
getting the picture no offense but it
sounds like some [ __ ] commie
gobbledygook
offense taken
oh
perfectly said though i couldn't agree
more yeah like if i see an american flag
pin i'm like oh he's either president or
he's a conservative yeah oh i always
just think that's clearly a nazi yes
that's what i go to yeah he had a he had
a tie that was american flag type and
had a bunch of little american flags and
i saw on twitter people were like oh
look at him he's got american flag he's
a white suprema
he seems like
hey you like the tie hey look get on in
there and see the flag it's got all the
odds
i like to have a joke
grandpa energy i love it yeah don't
worry it was just a gas bomb it was just
a gas bomb
i mean no you're your upper lip in a few
minutes you might want to keep an eye on
that because it's going to disappear
sizzle really oh he's not going down to
the quick stop and lit a dumpster on
fire we've all been i mean
who has not throw the first molotov
cocktail yeah yeah nice throw it back in
the car like those uh what do you call
them guineas in a bronx state yeah yeah
yeah yeah i can say that in port diego i
can't say that i am part-time part-whap
not not to be confused with the gross
vulgarities from that uh
that uh that megan horse yeah
somebody calling the horse whisperer
should get get her to stop talking it'd
be great if it was megan the stallion or
whatever song on his phone it's just
booty music
it's like ass kitties
like oh let me shut this off hold on
he's like i'm sorry i apologize i called
myself again just starts ringing black
and yellow black and yellow black i'm a
steelers fan what can i uh uh i'm gonna
put on my other ring put it in my mouth
okay
i'm gonna leave this in the office
oh yeah it's just a change because i
have custom ring tones for uh oh it
looks like the missus is calling my neck
my back
all right uh hey by the way do you
remember too the reason kyle writes went
down there keep in mind don lemon was
just saying i don't know why uh you know
kylo ren has been what if what if people
went to what if black lives matter went
down and burned stuff uh do you remember
when they covered all of those protests
and the riots in kenosha as mostly
peaceful here's just a flashback what
you were seeing the common theme that
ties all of this together is an
expression of anger and frustration over
what people feel like has become an all
too familiar story playing out in places
from across the country not just here
mostly those demonstrations in kenosha
have been mostly peaceful in recent days
jacob blake's family is among those
for non-violence
in kenosha and he spoke to people
gearing up for the president's visit
there
what are people
saying
tony a lot of different views as you can
imagine on the president's visit here to
kenosha today you know some folks we
spoke with welcome the president and say
that he can help heal and unify this
community the last night was very
peaceful
tuesday night
not quite so peaceful but it wasn't too
bad
monday and it was our was our big night
big night and kevin when i've talked
about the deck being stacked against cal
rittenhouse what are we talking about
the media we're talking about big tech
we're talking about being booted from
gofundme we were talking about being
booted just my tweets in support of him
on facebook let alone at the time being
booted from just being able to post his
side of the story or anyone posting his
side of the story we have the president
of the united states who compared him to
a white supremacist and we have the fbi
who sat on footage and didn't allow it
to be released until it really really
became an issue imagine being that
kid and also the d.a is uh relatives
with the mayor
yeah well imagine being that kid and
still appearing innocent i know yeah i
know that's all of that special against
you i i mean they just really must have
nothing you usually think like you know
they say you can indict a ham sandwich
you can well i guess kyle is more is
more teflon than a ham sandwich
[Music]
i mean claire mccaskill yesterday was
talking about how he went there looking
for this and littlefinger here who's you
know you know trying to question kyle's
little banger do you do you live
in kenosha he's like no but my dad does
oh well lots of
living
do you and i'm like that's not all it's
like his dad his aunt like on this
laundry list of his relatives live in
kenosha yeah and then he works there and
i'm just like
like mr binger do you sleep in a race
car bed by yourself
yes
is that unusual how did you know
i'm very hungry if you haven't realized
i'm terrible at this i hope that asian
food isn't delayed judge you're right
yes like uh i like to tell myself that
i'm in a phase it's like the jewel story
only you know without the talent
who will you save yourself not me right
not me or anything i've ever represented
no mine's hellbound for sure are they
casting for the prequel to lord of the
rings yet i could make it because well i
think that i could uh be a good stand-in
for the fiery pit that's just my story
i can't wait to see his closing
arguments it's like well you've seen
what i've done here and
it's
humanly possible and by car i mean my
bedroom yes yes absolutely
i uh i don't know they don't really have
a display room when i go to ikea for a
metro geo
i'll be hiding this is my fault i keep
looking it up i have a co-exist bumper
sticker i do yeah yes
with rioters is that one of them yes
well the problem is the c keeps eating
all the other letters hmm yes like
pac-man yes like well in the mrs pac-man
they make wear burqa you can't tell her
from the ghost it's not fair
on the back of my car i have a family of
three it's a pedophile a wife beater and
uh a career criminal yes and i've taken
down two of them and i also have a
sticker on the back of my car that says
if you can read this i'm defending a
pedophile so
i love that i had to have that one
custom
that's a bumper sticker and more i wrote
it with crayon if you can read this
you're too old for me
uh all right and by the way so here you
go the media labeled kyle just to be
clear when don lemon is talking about
how this guy was being praised the media
and the president labeled kyle
rittenhouse because they can never
forget this
when this kid is not guilty they labeled
him a white supremacist before they had
any facts here you go i don't know
enough to know whether that 17-year-old
kid
exactly what he did but
allegedly he's part of a militia coming
out of the state of illinois have you
ever heard this president say one
negative thing about white supremacists
yes a 17 year old
thing several times arguably a domestic
terrorist picked up a rifle drove to a
different state to shoot people you see
a 17 year old who was radicalized by
trumpism took his ar-15 to kenosha and
became a killer sucking on a lemonhead
not a hair on any of them
17 year old being held on suspicion of
first degree intentional homicide that
is weird i guess the sulfuric fires of
hell singe everything off though yeah
they do it's strange in advance yeah
it's like spawn he's like i don't have
all the information on this i'm only the
president yeah but i will put him in a
campaign ad uh being a white supremacist
yeah
right after the white supremacists yeah
and even when i get all the information
i won't remember it four minutes later
because i have the memory of a goldfish
yes and if i do remember it i'll be too
preoccupied cleaning my own [ __ ] from my
pants
it's from medicine hold on there's a cue
card they're telling me i am joe biden
yes i am i am
joe joe biden
what are you auditioning for snl he's
walking off
put on the aviators
what are they doing right now is he
still it's just going over yeah
just bring it up really quickly for
people who know and uh tweet this out
whichever
whatever trend is going is it cal right
now's trial written house trial college
we will get you that
gross christ
and he has a hard time with that name
gross craig
this [ __ ] here bro
this uh this lion prick over here yeah
oh i said another one of those oh no
what's the term uh what's the term when
a judge can just be like no we're not
doing a jury
a bench trial no not a bench trial where
he can it's not a quit what's the term
i'm looking for i keep forgetting this
it's not acquit the jury there can be uh
uh uh i keep forgetting the legal term
someone can send it to me in chat but
basically he can be like ah there's not
enough evidence for this to even be
going to trial this is ridiculous a
dismissal hung jury no not a hundred no
that's whatever they can this is a
dismissal he can dismiss the charges he
can dismiss the charges but there's a
term for what you would do with the jury
when you basically i believe they're
gonna change it to a written house yes
they're gonna change
that's the one so i think that there
obviously should be grounds for mistral
with prejudice and what does that mean
prejudice they can't charge them again
why this jury is every single attempt
has been made to intimidate the jury not
only from
from the media but you've seen it
actually taking place directly right now
there is a conscious effort to try and
intimidate them and make sure that they
know unless this kid fries there will be
riots in kenosha not to mention the
national guard has been put on standby
that's a veiled message to be sent that
some you know look it's in your hands if
you want your city to burn jurors um
protesters are outside the courthouse as
well right now of course almost like don
lemon was saying what if they were out
there trying to take chances into their
own hands it's almost like that's
happening from the people he supports
outside of the kenosha courthouse uh
which by the way they also tried to burn
down uh back then
but they're doing it right now
[Applause]
guess oh weird if we don't get it shut
it down okay
i like the okay sign poster that yeah a
lot of work went into that that's pretty
well done yeah that's pretty good well
that was better than if we don't get the
verdict we want uh alt control delete
reboot um
what is it about you
what is it about screwing the american
people i don't know i just get cat
couldn't scratch it oh hey so uh here's
also a man who claims to be george
floyd's nephew nephew i couldn't confirm
nor deny but uh
you know seems like an [ __ ] so uh i
don't know um but uh you know
i would bet uh he's the nephew saying
that they needed to take photos of the
jury this was out and publicly available
more intimidation i ain't even gonna
name the people that i know that's up in
the in the kenosha i mean the kenosha
trial but there's cameras in there yeah
it's definitely cameras up in there and
there's definitely people taking
pictures of the juries and everything
like that
so we need the same results man
tell me what you're going to do
it looks like crazy bone that's not yeah
it does yeah all right
at all it's a pool crazy bone favorite
banana you're not a fan i'm
judge schroeder actually said uh too
this is well known it was confirmed that
people were in fact trying to film so we
have no justice no peace if we don't get
it shut it down we have the national
guard uh right there in standby we have
allegedly uh george floyd's nephew
saying that we have people are going to
take pictures of the jurors and then we
actually have confirmed
evidence that the jurors were being
filmed where the judge had to shut it
down here you go this morning
at the pickup
there was someone there and was video
recording
the jury
which
the officers
approached the person and
required
him to him her i didn't even ask they to
um
delete the video
and return the phone to him um i've
instructed that if it happens again
there to take the phone why aren't they
arresting these people i don't
understand it yeah
if they are deliberately filming the
jurors it's a crime arrest them
arrest them you think they're doing it
for the good like out of good intentions
yeah it's not for doxing or anything no
no they're going to print it out and
sell pictures on ebay i mean what do you
think yeah no of course i love that like
we told them to delete it it's like oh
no yeah i delete sent to trash it's gone
yeah trash oh it's back up what are they
taking trump's phone what are you doing
delete set to trash i've never even
heard of the cloud
look sunny today
[Applause]
baby really saturday a dick did you see
what he did with he's a dick
turns out he's 5'3 yes turns out he's a
5'3 comedic jew
on a dying sketch show
[Laughter]
oh i think it's dead yes oh yeah oh yeah
postmortem
like a zombie it's his dead and that was
my dream as a kid me too but now i just
look at it and i go like what what is
this oh my gosh it's just well they
don't they the truth is the best talent
wouldn't go to snl you don't make enough
money and you don't get enough exposure
yeah no my friend shane got it and they
fired him and canceled him
look he dodged a bullet yeah no he did
he's now more he's not he's now more
famous than he would be if he was a
featured player on that trip well you
know what at least
they uh they protected the hilarious gay
asian who is uh bow and yang yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah hilarious and gay so
funny
yeah he's very believable as every
non-gay character that he plays i think
it just shows that you really are uh
awoke you know uh a person when it takes
you 45 years to put an asian on your
show yes
[Laughter]
look then nobody brought that up they're
like you know you had time i think in
living color did it after season three
they died 30 years ago
better late than never dave geez i know
that's jones but he but he was able to
check off two i'm not going to blame i'm
not coming i'm not going to be too hard
on snl have you seen him act
[Laughter]
yeah they do have a lady playing uh
oh no big about the vaccine how can this
be
yeah
perfect oh that's
great yeah one take you're great
they only get one take that's why it's
all so good i don't even need a cue card
i'm what i call a naturalist oh
so
don't defeat me after midnight now what
do i expect in today's closing
statements what do you expect there uh
here you can you can put it there in the
bottom quadrant view so people can see
and hey by the way by the way people
watching right now right now now smash
that like button if you want us to
continue streaming the closing
statements yes
smash the like button if you're watching
on youtube otherwise we're just going to
not we're just going to not stream the
written house trial yeah i like that
well yeah depends on you it depends on
you
yeah let's see i think you should like
okay what do you think is going to
happen what do you think the closing
arguments will be i think the closing
arguments will be uh well i failed at my
job
um i handed it over to the other team
uh i i caught the ball and then ran it
into their end zone yes
i think honestly i i'd like to say my
point of this where i thought honestly
when this happened because of all the
media that was coming in that he was a
white supremist who went there to shoot
black people because that was the
narrative and i actually thought until
the trial that the person who was shot
was a black person
now that i've watched the trial biasly
uh i do uh realize that uh i was
completely misinformed
and i would assume that he would be
found innocent in the only way he
wouldn't would be through complete
intimidation of the jury yeah well i
think it takes or if you believe two
pixels yes now see that takes a problem
it takes a lot of guts so to do to say
what dave just said now unlike i'll just
say anna kasparian over at young turks
who said the opposite of the truth
because she was doing the reporting i
know i said i wouldn't address them
since i buried but it was so to me very
[ __ ] it's like look look look look the
issue here is not i get that you
apologize when you're wrong like dave
just didn't say i was misled but i don't
understand how annika sprang at the
young turks like she said kyrie nels was
chasing joseph rosenbaum white supremacy
but here's the deal your job is to
report yeah your job is to report and at
that point you said this many many many
times you see this on the left there
there was hours of footage to prove it
incorrect
no footage has ever existed to
substantiate those claims so i don't
understand how they got it that wrong
unless it is a completely useless medium
right now it's a completely useless job
for someone to claim that they're a
journalist to be able to go out and say
white supremacists to be able to go out
and say militia cross state lines which
was said many many times over and over
and over and was chasing these people
how did you ever justify that if you
are in charge of reporting dave is
saying i listened to the reporting i
realized i was wrong the reporting was
all wrong that's the whole purpose to
this show that deserves high praise
what doesn't is when you're the one
reporting and i think yeah honestly the
closing arguments is going to be
somebody stating the evidence on the
written house side and then somebody
trying to make you forget it on the
prosecution side yeah that's really all
you can do i don't know the play like
what do you do when you go he could just
go crazy to try and hope for a mistrial
uh yeah i don't know at this point
closing he could i don't know i don't
know i think you're right though i mean
i think that is a possibility there's no
way he could win if they just dismissed
the gun charge yeah that's the easiest
one that i thought they're still going
for provocation with the the two pixels
like i said with that photo right
they're still trying to go for that so
that's probably what they're the photo
where they're claiming you aimed the gun
at someone yes that's their last name
they're throwing it at the end that's
less clear than e.t on atari
they don't have anything terrible it was
one of the worst games of all time
oh my gosh just i learned what rage was
yeah as a child because of that game
i would have rather been bullied outside
i didn't play that awful game yeah all
right go outside and get a wedgie yeah i
deserve it also uh michael also michael
jordan's chaos in the windy city on
super nintendo it is awful where you
fight giant spiders and you slam dunk in
random haunted houses it sounds like
hoops and you're rewarded with power up
wheaties like zombies and you beat them
with basketballs it's awful i got a
bargain bin at kb toys in plattsburgh
new york and i still almost hung myself
as a child and how dare you give us
jordan verse burden follow up with that
i know i know right next like don't
worry don't worry we've got something
coming down the pike with shaq food we
think you're gonna be really good
yeah we took a game that was already
made and we just added a basketball to
the main player yeah that's all they did
yeah and then michael jackson's jesus
juice yes right after that right in
there yeah yeah well that's really just
uh it comes with a free diet coke can
filled with a mystery liquid
what do you think is going to happen
yeah what did they give you a webcam to
set up for all the kids to play with uh
yeah just put this camera up here no no
that's a security camera make sure
you're safe and playing the game michael
jackson's on the other hand yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what do you think
there's according did i miss something
uh yeah i don't know he was saying jesus
jesus
jackson michael michael jackson
no jesus jews
i don't know if that's called jesus it's
not called jesus juice of course not
that goes like this
he seriously he saves kids throws little
sparkles on him and whoa saves kids in
the video you talk about throwing them
off the scent
manny going and pitching that one this
second it's like sega i gotta i got an
idea
like i don't know why do you feel now i
gotta save kids and of course i would
never touch him like why would we ever
include that why are you talking about
touching them that was never part of
this conversation there's only two
levels his house in court
no you forget the the street level where
he brings the kids all right
the final boss is an angry alcoholic
chimp yeah
yeah just a dead chimp dressed as elton
john
well it was a tuesday it was all right
someone will bring that up later if
there was actually a michael jackson
sega game what do you think to uh uh
what do you think you'll see in closing
statements so i i honestly feel like
he's going to be like the attorney and
uh my cousin vinnie who's like so proud
of himself walking back to the chair
jorah yeah exactly he's going to be that
guy i think he's going to go up there
and say you know we've laid out this
case that kyle rittenhouse was obviously
there he shouldn't have been there and
he's going to be chasing this guy and
he's the one that provoked this and he
shouldn't have shot that guy he
shouldn't have shot that like oh i think
he's going to say that and he's going to
think in his mind done a great job here
right i just don't i have no idea how
you can have any self-respect as an
attorney i understand why the da didn't
take this case and it's the assistant
d.a making the case he's like ah you
take it here
right but i just don't think he has
anything to go back to the jury which
usually you want to highlight your main
point right you want to highlight
something that was explosive in the
trial he doesn't have anything the only
things that have come out i think what
he's against him so what i think he is
going to argue is she was wearing a
short skirt she deserved it he is going
to argue that he shouldn't have been
there in the first place he is going to
argue that he went down there looking
for trouble ignoring the fact that for a
day and a half he was helping clean up
graffiti putting out fires he was
providing medical assistance he'll try
and character assassinate him he's not
actually a qualified emt all the while
avoiding the fact that the people who
died uh had a rap sheet that you could
not you could not random if you were a
horrible mass shooter and randomly shot
into any group of people and i god
forbid you ever did
wouldn't
by pure stroke of luck be able to hit
that kind of a rap sheet
five
five child molestation and rape charges
wife beating knife at brother's throat
domestic abuse uh uh misuse of firearms
you couldn't find i mean these guys
they're keep this in mind their rap
sheets of the three people who were shot
is longer than the list of crimes
committed all of january 6th that's not
a joke
yeah you could shoot into a prison and
not no
unless you shot right
they were all gang raping the child
rapist well that's true then you as a
power move
you could you could hit them then unless
you accidentally hit andy dufresne and
then you'd be like ah shoot oh we got
the one
come on yeah shoot in and the bullet
hits the poster everyone's like what the
hell oh
andy you screwed my whole plan well
don't don't forget gage's pending charge
right because i mean we're all about law
and order here he had he admitted on the
stand that he had an illegal firearm
right his his permit was expired yeah
yeah isn't that correct i mean i'm i'm
just yeah also he like when he's finally
keep in mind gage grove choice is suing
the city for 10 million failed to
mention that he had a firearm yeah and
in several statements said that he lost
his glock 27 if i'm not mistaken by
wrote generation 4 clock 27 40 caliber
you know what else he failed to mention
i spoke to kyle rittenhouse seconds
before and he said he was going to get
the police well you said you thought he
was an active shooter well
yeah i mean other people said get him to
be fair your honor
i was really high yeah well i i mean
so fast these questions are really tough
jeffrey toobin's speaking now oh really
i'm surprised he's not just masturbating
furiously
this is a rare moment this is like
catching a supernova jeffrey where's the
left hand yeah louis ck is that allowed
in the public eye and this guy's
evaluating a trial right you know
jeffrey toobin is watching this but on a
split screen he has three's company and
a box of tissues all right yeah let's
see
he's just resting in a tube of vaseline
by email
and then i'm reading them
and
little things are striking me as i read
them
um but the jurors are never told to
actually discuss self-defense except
except in the context of
charged offenses
and what i was about to say to the jury
and decided i better talk to you people
beforehand
is if the jury gets into a discussion on
people of uh first of a charge defense
any charge defense but let's use this
one as an example
um
and they decide that he's
the elements are there and he wasn't
acting lawfully in self-defense they're
done
they never they never discussed the
lessons what was there was not acting
lawfully
well let's see if they decide the
elements are there but he was
was uh
not acting lawfully in self-defense
they're done
then they find him guilty of the charged
crime
what if they
if they discuss kalman all right so he's
just talking about he's still just kind
of giving instructions generally
speaking i wanted to see what tuban was
saying didn't tuban call kyle written
house an idiot he did yeah he did he
said he was uh he said you can't
prosecute him for being stupid yeah well
fire
do you think there is a way i think
you're
just something you said earlier though i
think you make a point is there a
possibility that he is
the the prosecutor going to pull the i'm
one of the good ones and maybe just
throw the whole thing to protect himself
i mean it doesn't have to outwardly do
that if that's just an inner thought
which it seems that well no i mean more
so he's gonna throw it not to be a good
guy but it's kind of like you know when
a fighter throws a foul because they're
losing and you'll be like i would have
won that if not for the ref you know
that's what i think more so he would but
do you think there's some level of fear
to that um yeah i don't think he's going
to do it i'm just saying it's a
possibility at this point basically when
he is so far down on the score cards you
expect him to go rogue somehow so that's
what i'm thinking right yeah good he
could i have no idea he's desperate he's
a desperate man if it gets dismissed it
will be with prejudice at this point
because he would have earned i would
assume that's me just hopefully right
that you would dismiss it with prejudice
that you it would be obvious at this
point that he's throwing the case too
yeah oh and there are penalties for that
too like he if the judge suspects that
he's doing that on purpose like which he
stated on record he does not believe
well get it in good faith so let's let
me go through this to the prosecution
because this is the case they tried to
build right something that i think is
i had forgotten
the prosecutor little binger said uh
early on
he said early on he said we actually
have fbi footage that is not available
to the public which will show that when
we were watching this yeah which will
show cover now
frozen bomb or wow
i remember all of us live we're going
really i haven't seen that what he's
been sitting on this wouldn't that have
had to be wouldn't that have had to be
admitted to evidence and what's what's
going on um so that was what he said
would be the smoking gun
of course it wasn't but here let's take
a flashback clip k
this was a smoking gun yeah cal
rittenhouse trying to help
anybody need medicine
yes
and i think it was a white woman who
said
and they definitely need that trash can
to put their garbage
[Music]
has he considered opening his mouth all
the way when speaking yes you would
think so yes i'd rather he'd be a slack
jawed [ __ ] than a mush-mouthed
masker
that trashcan would make a good shield
for our next ride smashing the suvs
ah recycling big fan of that
[Music]
mesquite there's rosenbaum
[Music]
there's kelly zaminski for people who
don't know this is just the that aerial
footage
that's kind of with a fire extinguisher
with a fire extinguisher there's written
house running shows rosenbaum hiding
behind the cars written house runs and
then rosenbaum decides to run out
and chase him
they were showing this as though it
helped him
yeah
[Music]
by the way that that old footage watch
like it kind of looks like age of
empires
it
hey
now hold on a second let me just because
people might four different cameras
though sorry no no no no no i want to
i'll go back to it but i think do we
have the clip of
banger claiming in the pre-trial yeah
yeah because he was claiming this was
him saying that he's like oh yeah this
is actually this is going to prove our
point about that footage here you go
we're going to respond with an fbi video
that shows the defendant chasing down mr
rosenbaum and confronting himself oh we
just saw that's not what we saw we saw
the opposite terms
jackson stands for whether or not this
evidence is relevant to the elements of
the crime now keep in mind too there was
fbi hd footage that they lost you know
we talked about it somehow it ended up
getting leaked i don't know i guess the
fbi was like oh
that written house footage whoopsie i
thought you meant gary wright yeah i was
uh yeah i thought you said john ritter i
was like johnny winner he's dead
we don't need it it's the rules we got
here we should have clarified kyle right
now's footage yeah we have that
oh you want oh you want it you want me
to give it to you when you said you
asked if i had it you didn't say you
wanted it oh do you want the kyle
written house footage yes okay are you
sure because all you can do you can say
no to wanting it yeah yeah yeah you
might not want it i don't have to i
think about you know what you want you
know what
sleep on it i don't want to sleep on it
i don't want to you know what sleeping
on it is pretty good
and uh you know um uh i'll talk about it
yeah
let's talk about it with your wife i
don't make any decision without speaking
with a wife first you know
no i don't fbi give me the hd footage so
this is the footage that was found the
fbi hd footage
and again this is what keep in mind this
is what the prosecution thought would
make their case i don't know comment let
me know i want to see you guys coming do
i have a blind spot because i've been
watching all of this footage no i don't
see anything even remotely close to
supporting the idea that cal written
house was chasing anybody else here's
the hd footage
[Music]
running running running and then there
you go
runs around
goes back to check on him
then gets chased away again
by the way on cnn they uh we're talking
about twitter good morning america
saying a scary pursuit where the man
killed two protesters and they slow-mo
that shot so it looks like cal brookness
is coming back coming back oh my
goodness yeah
that's unbelievable yeah so if you look
at that original footage that i don't
know i mean i think we may have talked
about this but
is it zaminsky is that the guy's name
that was also there with rosenbaum that
they were saying kind of was his friend
that had a gun when he fired the shot
right so they looked at the slow motion
so when kyle's running up to put out the
fire rosenbaum is hidden behind a car
yeah but his buddy is pretty much in
front of kyle right right in front of
kyle kyle comes around to put it out you
see him
in that footage look at him and his
buddy looks like he has the gun in his
hand kyle takes a step back
looks to his right and there's rosenbaum
chasing him so kyle actually has a guy
in front of him and a guy right here and
now he has to run out and around to go
to get away like that for me looks like
his buddy was coming to kind of threaten
kyle rosenbaum was hiding to run around
like there's can i present another
theory
here yes
okay
i'm not saying i cannot substance i want
to be very clear i'm just this is
entirely speculation okay okay
uh rosenbaum mm-hmm right had taken off
your shutter file yeah yeah yeah yeah
serial child rapist had taken off his uh
shirt tied it around his face right yes
right and he ran out from behind
uh the uh the cars and was chasing cal
rittenhouse right and
as he was getting closer to kyle now so
he was yelling pardon my language [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you now yeah what i think may
have happened is
he had the shirt over his face mm-hmm
right we all keep in mind even though he
used the n-word that'll throw you off
he's true he's a ginger
right right and so i think kyle
rittenhouse heard the talent as he got
closer to the ooh
so he here [ __ ] you
you turned around saw a pale man with no
face thought it was a ghost
i think you're right i think he might
have been ghost hunting at least the
invisible man yeah
everything that guy just says [ __ ]
you can't say that
that is a therapeutic idea how
terrifying it is for a flat think about
this for a second a flabby serial child
rapist with a with effectively uh
balaclava tied around his face
screaming at you
in the middle of the night throwing his
throwing his mental asylum bag at you
what was that oh that was your discharge
bag
fan the hammer
it's the first time he ever took off his
shirt and covered his own mouth right
it's true
the bag said arkham on the side of it
why was he let out that day there's a
riot yeah yeah we're like yeah you can
get out there i think he's gonna have
some fun kids hey where's that anal
rapist yeah oh there you go there you go
wow hey have a good one so uh here's
something else too just to bring up
really quickly how desperate the
prosecution has been uh little banger i
mean we all know that he violated uh all
law and protocol by commenting on kyle's
fifth amendment right to remain sound
you've shown that but um
he also tried to tie the ar-15 that cal
written house used to call and then i
want to come back to a kind of a macro
point here before we go to closing
arguments as to why this matters this is
the most important trial i think
i think it's more important than
shopping i do as far as how it affects
all americans but this is clip p where
they're really grasping at xbox straws
it resembled the types of weapons that
are used in first-person shooter video
games correct
i don't really play first-person shooter
video games i have but i believe there's
a variety of guns including
shotguns pistols everyone there's guns
and video games that resembles lasers
isn't it true when you would hang out
with dominic black you'd play call of
duty and other first-person shooter
video duty sometimes
and those are games in which you use
weapons like ar-15s to pretty much
strong anybody who comes at you correct
it's a video game where two players are
playing together
i don't really understand the meaning of
your question
yeah isn't one of the things people do
in these video games try and kill
everyone else with your guns yes tipper
if you're good
yeah the video is just a little bit
video game is not real life yeah i i
remember life i remember from my days in
the arcade and then i went out and i uh
i actually uh i created an endangered
species by whacking gorillas with
mallets
i like to just go to a mushroom farm and
jump on them yeah jump on all of them
the guy comes out he's like i told you
to stop jumping on my mushrooms i'm like
you're asking for it isn't the whole
point of this game that your plan is to
shoot the ducks as they fly across the
screen not to mention how many turtles i
just eviscerated i mean i jump up and
down and get all infinite life just
absolutely did you know if you jump on
one turtle it it'll the inside goes away
and you can kick it in a bunch of other
yeah did you also know that when you
unfortunately if you
actually throw a frog
into a multi-lane freeway it just it
just dies yeah it's true it's not yeah
not fast but it only comes back three
times i've no i mean i've learned it the
hard way oh real you mean irl yeah yeah
it was just ectoplasm i hit a hedgehog
once with my car and it did not have
running shoes on really and i didn't
know if that was getting any coins or
nothing or like
knocking the running shoes off no maybe
that's what happened it was go you hit
it so hard you hit the running shoes off
it seemed much slower than i thought it
would be when i was chasing it right did
you did you know in this game when you
rip that man's heart out at again uh
with at the end with a fatality that uh
they they could die that's why i found i
found that out yeah yeah yeah yeah but
fatality yeah it doesn't really matter
so much though because uh he had it
coming because he was uh he was wearing
a rice paddy hat and he was clearly a
white guy yeah that's true that's
appropriate so i thought it was
appropriate to rip his heart out and no
one really complained yeah i tried to
rip his soul out couldn't find it no i
think he might have been in ginger too
uh by the way if you're being raped by
uh uh rosenbaum and your child hadoukens
do nothing ah yeah they don't work don't
worry nope no matter how many times you
yell not even a chun leak so to give you
give you a couple of examples
here um and by the way most sumo
wrestlers do not have reptilian
six-packs no no they don't yeah when you
hear finish him it's going to be a whole
yeah
[Laughter]
get out of here
so what's so funny to me is remember
back in the day there was you know no
effects and rage against machine and
rock against bush man and they they
tried to say oh conservatives right
christians can you believe it they're
trying to censor stuff well really was
tipper gore with the rating labels but
let's go back to even south park south
park christian activists just didn't
want them on
in prime time and actually yeah went to
a uh a speech that uh i can't remember
if it was matt or trey was giving it uh
at ut austin because my brother was
there and he said we actually agreed
with christians he never tried to get
her shows banned yeah he said it wasn't
like comedy central banning us for
putting muhammad in our show because
they said he can't do that as his
christians didn't want us to be on in
the daytime but we wanted a more lenient
rule set so we wanted to be on later at
night so christians really just wanted
the ability to control content for their
kids as far as what they're watching but
think about this right now all of these
arguments with violent video games and
post columbine these leftists these
people who tried to make it seem like
that was old fogey conservative right
now none of them have complaints from
what you're seeing
with binger presenting these arguments
and also keep in mind these same people
rage against the machine and for fight
against the system are the people who
are showing up and beating the [ __ ] out
of
anti-vaccination mandate protests
at what point do you start to say oh
they're the fascists they said well
muscle let's blame violent video games
we need to what's the solution ban
violent video games you're only using it
when it's convenient to yours for
yourself you're pro freedom but you
support vaccine mandates you support
lockdowns you don't believe that people
have the right to defend themselves you
don't even believe in the god-given
right to self-defense this is what's
happening here right now look
this is really concerning
this is the left right now with cal
written house what they want to do and
there's going to be a supreme court case
uh as it relates to new york and if you
the right to
keep and bear arms allows you to carry
firearms which of course it should uh
but what the left is doing for example
when you see they have gage gross quotes
on cnn and on good morning america
because they know he can lie right he's
no longer under oath what they're doing
is saying well we don't care if it's
true or not if we don't win in the
courts if we don't win in a legal system
um we'll just make you so afraid to
defend yourself that the second
amendment is all but irrelevant that's
what they are trying to do right now
they know that if you are out
there and someone is burning your
business down and someone throws a
molotov cocktail or a gas bomb or even a
brick in the building with you in it
and you happen to have a gun
and they storm you and they kick you
right they assault you they hit you with
a skateboard and you use a firearm to
defend yourself that you still will have
your life ruined look i don't even think
the prosecution cares right now if
they're going to win or not kyle right
now says unless he gets a sandman nick
sandman uh type scenario with cnn and
with the media and i hope he doesn't
help him yes he doesn't have to pay
these bills for the rest of his life his
reputation his life is already ruined in
a lot of ways that's their goal in the
first place this is designed to
intimidate all americans it's not an
accident that they were praising we are
talking about at minimum the tally was a
year ago four billion dollars in damages
right we're talking about the protests
we're talking about thousands of arrests
we're talking about hundreds of
casualties right we were talking that
went on for a long time mostly peaceful
one kid shot a serial child rapist
and another man look let's also be do
you know how i know and do you know how
you know that they don't care
why was this kid there with a firearm he
wasn't supposed to have well the charge
was just dropped because he actually was
within the realm of the law carrying
that firearm because he was 17 and it's
a long gun in wisconsin that same
question could be asked about the gage
spacers guy you had on your show being
an [ __ ] he had a weapon he'd have a
permit for that weapon
he was somewhere he had no right being
and he initiated an attack it's very
easy this is something a lot of
conservatives will they'll get into and
they'll get into the legalese and well
let's go back and forth no no look look
look let's think about this the quickest
path to victory okay the quickest way to
shut it down well what was kyle doing
there you first
what were your guys doing there
he was looking for trouble okay the day
leading up to it he was providing
medical care
he was putting out fires he was washing
off graffiti what were your guys doing
oh the one guy was being discharged from
mental
hospital was the other guy doing
oh he was there among the looters and
the writers and oh okay all right so
let's just look you answer first
yeah no it doesn't it does make like if
they do take away your ability to defend
yourself you're right it does make the
second amendment irrelevant much like
when barack obama i believe he spoke
about taxing ammunition yeah and making
it so expensive that okay fine you can
have the firearm but you can't have
anything that goes in it or in
california where they have the laws that
say you can only have so many rounds the
capacity limit right dc in california i
think maybe even new york too
now you can't protect yourself in in
this case kyle kyle if kyle had had a
handgun in that case and he would have
had to play by those rules yeah he had
four shots and then he had i think
another four or three or four shots
total at the end he may have run out i
know well sorry the last guy running up
with a gun to shoot you
click oh it didn't i got nothing what do
you what do you call a timeout do you
know what i see when i see cal run i
don't know about you i see i go oh
well of course we need high-capacity
magazines yes yeah
revolver is not going to cut it well
especially when every i've seen so many
people call his weapon an assault rifle
right it's pretty unbelievable well dave
it does have the letters a a r
yeah that's what they think stands for
assault rifle stands for arma light yeah
i love it when they fall into that trap
though it's just really funny
this is really though to me i go i go oh
okay this is
an assault rifle sorry no this is uh
what do you mean you mean a pull a
trigger and it goes bangs and
projectiles come out oh okay that's all
rifles yeah you mean it's more effective
all the better to kill pedophiles with
my dear it's a salty for school shooting
like it doesn't make any sense to call a
gun that
well look and then what do you end up
with murder with people you end up with
people in the uk who go to prison for
defending their homes with knives yeah
or for instilling fear in criminals who
are robbering the houses with a lego gun
that has happened with replica guns you
end up being and look let's just think
about this look for real yeah this is
these are actual cases that have
happened in europe let's just think
about this for a second okay
what
what would you what would you rather
have happen right what would you
honestly have asked this question before
what would you have rather had happen to
kyle written house
and what's what's the better alternative
they're saying we can't have a country
where you have people going out there
and taking the law into well we have a
country where cities are being burned
down
and people are being killed
i think it's a better i think it's a
better country
i really do
and i just i don't know how at this
point someone can argue against
think about this where the line of
questioning i'm just trying to go
through my mental rolodex how stupid it
was where binger said and we don't have
the clip here but he said
so you were on your back and uh
this man who hit you did you see a gun
no sir did you see a weapon a knife or a
chain or any kind no sir so you shot him
because he was kicking you with one foot
so if a woman's being raped by a six
foot five 250 pound linebacker
she can't shoot him she has to wait
until he's penetrated her and she sees a
gun yeah
they don't want you to protect they
don't want you to be able to defend
yourself and this and there is no
accountability do you know how i know
there's no accountability for the actual
criminals because gage gross kurtz is on
good morning america and it
he has nothing to lose you know why no
because he has he's not telling the
truth kyle has to remain silent we're
being charged because he's being yeah
this guy was going out and suing the
city for 10 million so he has a vested
interest in kyle being guilty he has no
nothing to lose just oh well i guess i
lied media is not going to call me on it
my life won't be destroyed people just
forget yeah and by their logic you know
you basically could apply that okay
reginald denney as these guys were
pulling you out of your truck did you
see a weapon no i didn't see a weapon
oh okay so
what you know if he had had a gun and
fired on these people
by their logic he would have gone to
jail we know what happened that reginald
denney didn't have a weapon these guys
didn't have a weapon initially so they
were just gonna kick your ass right
that's okay well no actually later on
they came up with bricks and then then i
think there was like a fire hydrant or
some big thing that they hit me over the
head and by the way i can't even put
this sentence together now yeah because
my brain doesn't work right anymore
right so that's what we're supposed to
allow to happen to all of us we he
didn't see a weapon you weren't in fear
for your life so somebody can just beat
the crap out of you and make it to where
you can never you know feed yourself
soup again they're not they're not
taking
in account all of the other people that
were attacking them at the same time
what they do with these trials they can
separate each instance out and watch
slow motion video
all of that happened was happening at
the same time four people were attacking
him at the same time why they chased him
down they want you all to watch this
they want you all to watch this and the
reason they are gaslighting you is they
want you all every single american right
now watching to go wait a second
the guy's chasing him gunshot saying
he's going to kill him [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
when he shoots him i don't know that
seems and they want they want you to see
them saying despicable
white supremacist this man needs to get
the death penalty they want you all to
see the 17 year old kid on his back
getting his face stomped and getting hit
with a skateboard in the head defending
himself
and they want you while your natural
inclination is to go well that seems
pretty they want you to see them going
can you believe this child this is a sad
state of america we must hang him and
they start intimidating the jury they
want you to see kyle rittenhouse on the
ground when a when an absolute hooligan
with spacers in his ears who's
ironically named gage runs up on him
tries to fake him out with his hands up
points a gun at his head point blank and
kyle rittenhouse has the trigger
discipline to only vaporize his bicep
and they want they know that your
inclinations go oh my god i can't
believe that he only shot him in the arm
i mean that's actually that's actually
very merciful they want you to see don
lemon saying this is not america we have
to stop this we can never let this
happen again why they want all of you to
be afraid and they want all of you to be
victims every step along that way they
would have preferred you be one of the
the miners who was raped because it
gives them more control they would have
preferred
that you have your head bashed in with a
skateboard or you get american history x
into the concrete and not do anything
because that gives them more control
they would have preferred that the guy
with the spacers in his ear come up and
shoot kyle written house because that
would give them more control you know
why because they never charge these
criminals
hey why have we just forgotten about
hoodie man yellow pant jump kick man
yeah you know i mean there's enough
security footage there did no one see
where he sauntered on off to
seriously in bright yellow in bright
yellow
dressed like dressed like uh like the aj
from the backstreet boys
he was the cool one
yeah it was but it was a bad one
well he returns videos without rewinding
them and [ __ ] yeah oh wow
what a jerk
seriously no we're just gonna skim past
that yeah i mean there there are plenty
of people that you can charge there's
plenty of people and you remember like
this police weren't just walking around
there
like they had left this area right they
had let they had let people take over so
tell me what you're supposed to do you
live in a town where it burned the night
before
it's burning again tonight
and the police have all gone home and
you have no one to protect yourself and
then don lemon saunters on out and says
yeah but it's not your neighborhood not
your street not your anything to protect
right right it that okay so i just die
my family and i we just we we die it's
only a gas bomb maybe it doesn't burn
the house let me ask you does everyone
who is the militia
does anyone know that this is something
too right when they can someone actually
just bring up the second amendment i
want to read it word for word right here
the mouth militia it's a song on the
judge's phone yes yes
along with my neck my back no it's not
crap oh i don't want to get to the part
where she starts talking about uh her
[ __ ] we'll call it up no way ladies not
that's only talk when i'm hanging from
my you know uh
lotion sex hammock there i got a quite a
swing yeah last week yeah you know my
wife just uh sent me a picture of three
cats yeah so time to resist yeah
sometimes i break here sometimes i put
my house keys in the wrong jar
at a party
i put a pineapple out by the door who
knew you have no idea you don't know
what you're dealing with pineapple's not
in season you don't put that by the door
well you do it's not going to ripen uh
the second amendment here let's bring it
up where we can hear put it it is the
right
a well-regulated militia can we zoom in
there comma
a well-regulated militia right isn't
there a comma there comma yeah zoom in
again there uh you know what you ready
for me token because i want to make sure
the commas here really matter a
well-regulated militia comma being
necessary to the security of a free
state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms comma shall not be in french keep
that up there for a second
okay a well-regulated militia comma
being necessary to security of a free
state come we're two commas away from
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringement they
could have just said keep they could
have just said own firearms they said to
keep and carry firearms
uh you can bring bring it off keep in
mind at this point in uh in time in the
country i don't believe there were any
laws that you could pretty much open
carry any firearm that you had at that
point as far as i understand it so it's
written at a time where if that was a
concern it would have been included a
well-regulated militia comma then it
says the right of the people to keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed well
what does that mean when people try to
say it's for the militia hold on a
second
we're separated here from the a
well-regulated militia comma being
necessary to security of a free state
comma the right of the people to keep
and bear arms and there's quote after
quote after quote why who is the militia
it is we the people the entirety of p i
believe george mason was the one who
made that quote you can find george
mason second amendment we the people
uh militia if you type that in you'll
find it i'm going by rote i know there's
one by thomas jefferson it's very clear
all of you are the militia and the
militia isn't just to fight off the
world's greatest superpower who let
their number one draft pick get away
sorry but it's also to fight internal
threats like i don't know
gas bombs and murder in the streets of
your town yeah
and they want you to be afraid they want
you to think we are so far what are you
suggesting that i am not suggesting that
anybody go out and hunt anybody i'm not
suggesting that anyone go out and pull a
charles bronson death wish
what i am suggesting however is
enshrined into our constitution when
people are burning down your
neighborhoods and throwing gas bombs
molotov cocktails bricks if they are
pulling you out from your cars if
they're smashing your car while you are
in it which we've seen countless times
they are forfeiting their right to live
and if these people are organizing and
burning down city blocks like we saw in
kenosha
i don't know this is i don't understand
why it's any more offensive
for people to organize
and fight against the violence as it is
for the organizers and perpetrators of
the violence in the first place i don't
understand why one is considered more
offensive
outside of the fact that the left of
course wants a victim society under the
thumb of big government look let's just
let's just say you believe that all
violence is immoral call it a wash
why is one offensive when someone
responds to ring ring hello what they're
burning down my business for the third
time gas bombs oh no i have price what
if you have priceless items in there
since when did since when do we have to
say oh only if i really think right now
i'm about to die do i have the right to
defend myself that's very silly it's
very new
you have the right to protect life and
limb you don't have the right to use
lethal force when protecting property
but you know what that's also murky
because what if you are in the property
yeah what if somebody else is in the
property what if i mean people always
say well the businesses you know protect
they were chanting this
leading up to this protect your property
not the street your property not the
street it's like okay well you're
starting to steal our property and take
it out that dumpster right that they
were taking out there right what do you
expect that every business has insurance
do you remember the riots in la that
that just iconic footage that we have of
this guy screaming at the people in the
street because he didn't have insurance
on his business and they had destroyed
it and it was just hard remember rooftop
koreans yeah they were trying to protect
not everybody has the insurance and by
the way even if they do not everybody
can survive that okay the insurance pays
but then your business is destroyed and
people have moved on to other businesses
and now you have to rebuild like what do
you think happens it's obvious you've
never run a business and i want to go
back to the second amendment thing and
why is it i'm going to just to to be
more basic with it why is it more
offensive for a business owner to want
to protect his livelihood violently than
it is for you to take it violently yeah
i don't understand it why is it
considered more offensive
for a business owner to violently
protect his business when you are
violently destroying it
well also during a time too while
they're struggling to stay afloat now
you're jacking up insurance rates for
every single person on the block and
within a several mile radius i know hey
the closing arguments are starting
uh right now they're saying okay all
right did you have a point you were
about to make their jail because then i
really really yeah the second amendment
thing like the way that that should read
is so that we can form a militia that
people must be armed basically saying
sorry the founding fathers didn't have
you on retainers no they wrote it that
way but people people don't understand
english apparently and they can't read
into that and it's like look you are
never i they could have said this to us
and it would have been the same you are
never to give up firearms and make them
centralized to a state to a government
to a city to a militia group and by the
way as the weapons and you don't really
take them you are never
not the militia yeah just to be clear at
every moment of every day you are the
militia some people might create
factions of militia where they're
organized or they coordinate together
you are the militia every minute of
every day that's what the second
amendment says yeah that's how we fought
the world's greatest superpower one
century to become the only world
superpower the next century never been
done before or since
you are the militia you are always the
militia this is not a call to violence
it's a call to responsibility so you
understand the importance and why it is
grafted in to our basic human rights in
the united states constitution not
granted by government
simply recognized by god and a document
to say government you cannot infringe
upon these there's there's a huge huge
difference none of these rights are
granted by government you
watching right now listening
you are never anything but the militia
every second of every day every single
american let's be really clear about
that and take that responsibility
seriously so we don't burn down more
innocent businesses are they uh are they
doing the opening statements let's see
where they are in the morning all right
can you guys can you guys hold it down
while i go to the restroom really
quickly yeah one thing also for the
viewers youtube is trying to take down a
lot of uh other channels that are
streaming this using like audio
copyright strokes so we are going to
need to talk and give talk and go back
and forth so yeah so everybody if you
want to hear the audio uninterrupted
tune in to cnn court tv whatever on
another channel okay um and keep us up
we'll comment over this to make sure
that we don't run afoul i'm going to
bring joe lewis out too it looks like we
both have to go you might need to go by
the way i was going to go in here this
is this is a perfect example of where
you need to have us on rumble as well
right so follow us on humble if you're
not watching this on rumble right now
and you're on youtube and something
happens go over to rumble you'll be able
to find us uh that way they can't remove
i mean why would you be
getting people off of this like come on
like this
the whole week prior to this too not
striking people but now right last day
striking people when it becomes very
obvious that they have nothing wonderful
a fresh dislike or no dislike button
right
right yeah what an odd coincidence final
decision but i certainly will
try to follow your wishes so how long do
we have on that how often do we need to
oh he's starting yeah
here we go good morning ladies and
gentlemen i want to assure you that
everything that the judge just read to
you you'll get a copy of so you'll have
a chance to look it over yourself you
don't have to have one suit i just told
you
i think it's no surprise
that this is a case that there's a lot
of uh noise and a lot of uh static
surrounding it
so what i'd like to do at the beginning
is crystallize it in a nutshell for you
and keep it in a nutshell that's good
yeah it's very helpful this is a case in
which a 17 year old is going to briefly
kill two unarmed men ah severely wounded
a third person who was armed i'm going
to take out every detail in what i'm
about to say this isn't a situation he's
protecting his home what do you mean
that he knew he couldn't his family they
dismissed the gunshot people after
traveling here he wasn't unarmed
illinois he had a chain staying out
there that's true city-wide curfew
objects the objection to it
curfew charge anymore there's no
gun charge
correct although he claimed he was in
charge but just saying um and and and
they're
they're also talking about when to
start deliberations the jurors are
saying they want to start deliberation
tomorrow but the judge will make the
final call gotcha but there had been a
curfew announced
uh that does not mean
that
um it was technically lawfully us
put in place legal curfew yeah but there
had been an announced curfew so i'll
leave it at that not a lawyer but it did
stay on an expression all the rest of us
here in kenosha were aware
and i think most people most reasonable
people obeyed
although except for the right except for
all the writers all the people you say
he uh he shot killings in this case the
people in their house just crying their
eyes out from fear right yeah he also
spent the entire got a very quick
breaking news update about alex jones
when steven returns to okay oh oh he was
right again tease me without something
is it bad oh no
so when we think about the defense let's
see how this goes i'd like you to
consider as you think about i'm watching
with you by looking down at my
motivations
was this a situation where he sincerely
cared about
car source even though he'd never heard
of it no jeez never bought anything
there never worked there and not even
its owners
were out there that night protecting it
because he was only interested in
helping people
he ran around with an ar-15 all night
and lied about being an emt do you think
the people care that we're receiving
treatment from him whether he lied about
being an emt or not
he's not there maybe he's a 17 year old
that was just like yeah i'm an empty
i've been trained
so why was he there really that's a
crime now yeah
when you think about these things i
think there are some things that we can
all agree on but it was self-defense in
america it's hard these days people are
polarized and there's a lot of behind
them like political issues
[Laughter]
raise your hand if you agree life is
more important than property and all of
you raised your hand
of course we also agree doesn't mean you
don't know one person's life
is more valuable than another
what kind of problem you don't get to
kill someone simply because they're a
drug dealer
you don't wait i mean i i do if they're
attacking you and trying to kill you is
it rosen's bomb rosenbaum's life because
everything i have is more valuable
than a cereal
here that we shouldn't have 17 year olds
running around our streets with ar-15s i
don't agree why not because this is
exactly what happens good defends
himself and doesn't die you're right
finally this is what happened to keep in
mind that we've all read stories and
heard about heroes
that step in by kyle rittenhouse to stop
an active shooter or to give their life
spider dave
in fact many people in wisconsin went
out and got carrying concealed weapon
permits just so that they could be there
in case there was an active shooter and
wanting to stop them but he was not an
active shooter
but i'm saying it's good they all got
concealed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah gage gross
they have a preconceived notion so guys
i know that they mentioned sorry so i
guess we have to talk a lot because yeah
yeah because they're going to try and
ding us okay look if if we do get
removed from youtube though then we'll
go to rumble and all the stuff that we
can't say on youtube we just say that we
just say it and we're monitoring that
right now if we see enough people going
oh i just got nauseous for example i
took some of that uh like i have this
collagen protein disgusting
are you gonna bomb on the mic i might a
lot of
face
breaking news this is from the new york
times just a few minutes ago breaking
news a connecticut judge ruled alex
jones was guilty by default granting a
sweeping victory for the parents suing
the far-right broadcaster for defamation
over the sandy hook shooting nope he's
gonna have to appeal
all right let me listen to this guy's
[ __ ] and without the legal authority
to do so
and when you think about the defense too
many people only see what they want to
see with them i don't know hold on a
second i guess i guess i do i'm like
because
is that a mirage no that is a pedophile
getting it no it's really happening
other people's lives it's like when i'm
hungry he starts looking like a hot dog
so when i talk to you here
in my closing and huber didn't give his
life to save others on the murders
that the defendant he tried to
second i'm going to address some
background issues give you some context
and talk about some of the
things that i don't think are relevant
to this case
facts and videos
my colleague jim krause and i have tried
to present you with all of you
don't call me colleague that we can you
should continue don't leave me right now
he's like did we order more asian food
at the end of this you would be the
expert really like he's the detroit fan
that wears a bag over his head oh yeah
all about this case so people tuning in
sorry they're gonna hit us if we don't
have it up so you can bring it up on
scene and watch along with us it's not
like he's saying anything all that
substantive to be clear no no no no he's
just saying he's gonna leave out all the
evidence yeah essentially what he's
saying he's one step away from saying
you can keep the spirit of christmas in
your heart all year long
and these are letters from santa yes for
two cents
whoa number four he pretended to guard a
building
no regarding it he actually guarded a
building claiming well he's fraudulently
claiming to be an emt keeps going back
to this i mean he lied about being an
emt guy he's been on the on the slide
well if he pretended to guard a building
then what are we talking about yeah
exactly just excuse the little thing
well then look he pretended to shoot
rosenberg
he was just out larping like in that uh
role models really then who gives a crap
yeah then it's fine oh my gosh there
were other people
who came along to protect car source or
ultimate gas or other businesses and
many of them were armed with ar-15s yeah
just like the defendant mm-hmm good in
fact you know the difference you're
going to see they weren't attacked they
weren't attacked
there who granted was also an [ __ ]
but not attacking kyle rittenhouse yeah
safe is in mother's arms yeah
[Laughter]
yelling they're shouting there's even
shoving you know this seems to be a
little bit of a difference in this
entire season
three grown men who went after a kid
because he was a kid
how do you not see this everything this
community that's also to me this is also
a great lesson the fact that a firearm
is a great equalizer
what i mean i want more kids to be able
to shoot would-be pedophiles yes yeah i
think i think it was real neat what he
did to that guy
do you imagine if corey haim was a
better shot
he'd still be alive today
i'm gonna have a lot a lot of bullets
though and michael jackson would still
be where he's at yeah
yeah i'm prosecuting joseph's youtube
well you know what at least michael
jackson is tangling babies from
balconies in hell that's true
or in heaven
but guys yeah
sir so let's keep that in mind
so did he
go to the basketball game
and the murder
of joseph rosenbaum no not murder
because it's all captured on video
we watched
are we watching the same thing it is
it's all on video 63rd street car source
mr rosenbaum is ahead
of the defender don't you dare say come
on in the fbi video when mr rosenbaum
starts to run the defendant starts to
run as well at the same time as if he's
perceived no no no no no no we just
watched the republicans can we bring up
the footage again come on the footage at
that point where rosenbaum starts
chasing kyle right now is the fbi
footage the
the one that has uh
the
the aerial footage not the drone but um
[Music]
yeah okay look so he just said it's very
clear that
cal rittenhouse only starts to run once
rosenbaum starts to run let's be really
clear here just so you know that he's
lying let me show this to you in real
time look at the top left there's
rittenhouse he's running rosenbaum hides
and then
rosenbaum comes around
right here runs on up to cal written
house only then does kyle start running
at no point can it even be argued that
he was chasing him zaminski or whatever
that guy's name is chase him you can see
him running back from and you'll get him
get him get him and remember ridden
house is carrying a fire extinguisher
fire extinguisher yes his his weapon
well it's the weapon of choice for white
supremacists yes yeah because they
always have to put out the cross they're
burning
it's totally responsible
did they cut the audio or oh no no no
he's just uh he's just [ __ ] he's
just praying for more please god he's
praying for a miracle drone video full
he's gonna always about to show it
except please do he's gonna lie before
and jim will point out to you here in a
second on the screen
when the defendant originally arrives at
that scene the first thing you see him
do is drop the fire extinguisher and
point
his weapon at people
and then the chase occurs right after no
why did he have to drop you're gonna say
the question is
it's because zaminski was standing right
in front of him with a gun it's on the
video how do you not see that and he
does he does he's just hoping that you
think your eyes are broken and by the
way you know what he didn't do
kyle didn't shoot yeah you know what
this should be the driver's test from
now it's like uh hey uh do you see kyle
running house running away from the
pedophile yes you're good to drive
oh that's after thank you he's being
chased
as he's being pursued and points the gun
at mr rosenbaum and then as he enters
the area between the parked cars he
slows
because there's nowhere to run there's
nowhere to go he's being chased by a
pedophile ghost
shooting and knocking him to the ground
no no just say it shooting and killing
him
yes
because he was trying to kill kyle
should be honest he grabbed his gun yeah
no no it was friendly
shaking a hand
shaking the muzzle there i'll show you
this it was really more fist pounding
the gun right
and mr krause is going to help me by
directing your attention on the larger
screen here too exactly it's going to
distract you that's what he's going to
do
you don't want to look over here gosh it
feels like rocky and bull ankles like
we're going to
must have picked the wrong hat
all right all right gonna do the
provocation they're gonna point it out
where's the provocation i i don't see
any nope none come on is he wearing a
short skirt
he was asking for it stephen i'm going
to replay it a few times oh that's it
clearly that is it quite clearly
the fire extinguisher on the ground
with his left hand
and then brings his left hand over to
the gun yeah and raises it and points
because zaminsky had a gun in his hand
show that footage you have it hey hey
let me just ask your guys zaminsky
rosenbaum gage
when did they put their fire
extinguisher down
in other words if he's putting his fire
extinguisher down and he's on camera
several times putting out fires that
means that there's a long record of him
throughout the day putting out fires
when were your people putting out fires
they were starting them that also
matters yeah keep keep showing that by
the way he had a fire extinguisher two
put down under wisconsin law
you're not allowed
to run around and point your gun at
people
this is also allowed to light car
sources on fire it starts this incident
no no it is not
rushes in and immediately points the gun
no
and as you'll see in a little bit oh my
god sure rosenbaum doesn't take kindly
to people pointing guns no i don't think
anything that's at the euphemism
though whoa he pointed a gun at somebody
else and rosenbaum is entitled to chase
him down and try to kill him mr
rosenbaum being the concerned pedophile
citizen that he is it doesn't take
kindly to minors oh my gosh matter of
fact it's almost a pet peeve of
rosenbaum he lists it on his
pedophilematch.com miners with guns
the defendant comes running in and drops
the fire extinguisher on the ground like
this
and then raises his left hand to the gun
and points
this is what we see in the video where
the hell is he pointing that gun
extinguisher
is he the uh
that's an argument
okay
he's facing the wrong direction he just
aimed it at his co-prosecutor
now what he's saying is he didn't name
it rosenbaum
at all reaching for the gun holding it
up
you can see it again on the video here
please pull his left arm reaching up
imagine that it's there now just as you
can't really see just do do me a favor
why would he running to put out a fire
folks saying
does anybody need medical why would he
drop the fire extinguisher and
immediately take a defensive position
with his firearm and not fire targeted
as a person that had a gun and start
taking steps backwards right which is
what he did on the aerial footage and
then wheel around and see rosenbaum
do you think he just saw a guy no he saw
the same guy that he saw earlier with
rosenbaum and he had a gun and he had a
gun and he was when he fired the first
shot yeah
then we have the chase that occurs after
that we just want to and we have taken i
just want to punch you hold on the chase
is getting into the chase the pedophile
portions of that chase
and then the defendant turns and points
the gun back at mr he does and this is
the moment in time when mr rosenbaum
essentially does sort of a little hop
with both of his hands in the air when
what and the defendant has testified
he saw at that moment that there was
nothing in the defendant's hand or mr
rosenbaum what the hell is he talking
about
yeah this is this is [ __ ] there's
the defendant turning and pointing the
gun yep and then he turns again and runs
away stands out to the see
and then continues running yeah and now
a gun shot this is where the shooting
occurs bang gunshot goes off and then he
shoots him to be clear that's why he's
playing this without audio to be clear
someone can have no gun in his hands
like me right now guess what no gun in
my hands i'll play the gun in my holster
i can pull it out and either gun
so if you point a gun at someone who's
screaming at you that they're going to
kill you screaming [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you a shirtless pedophile ghost
what you just saw there's cowboy now
turn okay no gun at this point continue
running reaches a dead end right the
barricade of cars hears a gunshot and
turns around and the guy is lunging for
his gun keep in mind just because
someone doesn't have a gun
one second doesn't mean they don't have
a gun on their person
this is absurd he heard a gunshot and
saw a pedophile ghost trying to for all
he knows trying to rape him like he did
five other kids yeah you never know by
the way correct me if i'm well with
rosenbaum you kind of know but you kind
of know in this case
so he said he wasn't within arm's reach
when he shot him rather how far away he
said he's not even within arm's reach uh
he grabbed look right there
look look he still doesn't shoot only
when he yes he has burn marks on his uh
yeah he had burn marks on his hands you
can see from this video that mr
rosenbaum is not even within arm's reach
of the defendant what are you talking
about this is this is this is the left
this is the left just don't believe
you're lying eyes and ears he's not in
arm's reach you are watching him look
right now look
he is he is not only in arm's reach he's
in elbows reach can
to get power at the end of a punch you
ever heard the term pushing your punches
down pushing your punch means you can't
fully extend it right you want to punch
someone at the end
he's too close to even extend a punch
step he's in grappling distance on the
aerial footage from the effort this is
not
that perspective i understand that as
the prosecutor you're supposed to try to
make your case yeah but you're not
supposed to do obvious lies to do it
well he's a lawyer now so here's but
here's the thing like in our justice
system you don't want the prosecution to
have to make stuff up
when there's an obvious explanation for
what happens it's not you don't want
them to have to make stuff up you don't
want them to ever make it no i don't
want them to make stuff up i want them
to just present the case right so
i understand he's not going to take into
account
50 people over there how can the
prosecutor present the case that's the
point he's really he's stretching his
hands are zip tied
they really are he could have burn marks
on them
no i mean you're lying saying he's not
in arms right she's like oh but if i'm
the defense footage i come up and i'm
like yeah you know he said he wasn't
within arm's reach then how did he have
a burn mark from the barrel of the gun
it's almost like it had kr written in
his hand you know like from home alone
because he grabbed the gun as he fired
kyle just happened to brand that part
right yeah directions
just pisses me off because that's not
justice
uh no it's not justice but i think we
are going to see justice i pray and i
hope
well true justice would be kyle never
has to work another day in china uh yeah
yeah
and don lemon has to take yet another
pay cut yeah yeah and don lemon's not
allowed to go to protest because i
wouldn't be surprised to see him chase
down a minor and try and be like taint
juice
shot
gosh
that's likely because they heard the
first shot
at a certain point because they always
just admitted to run away zaminsky the
defender fire testified that that shot
from mr zaminski
had nothing to do with his decision to
kill joseph rosenbaum uh
the gunshot
that took place and then he turned
around finally i don't know i think that
any gunshot would be relevant if people
are telling you that they're going to
kill you behind all of this
and then he comes upon mr
rosenbaum's body
they're probably not going to show this
because i think it's pretty graphic
oh they've showed it before
is that audio playing
playing a song i don't know he's not all
right can you text brian please
darn it
that's where rosa mom was hiding oh your
honor did i say that out loud i'd like
to strike that from the record yeah yeah
yeah i think what i meant to say is
that's where he was
looking over his uh
child weekly magazine yeah he was trying
to protect people from having a gun
pointed at them
that's not kyle firing by the way
anymore those last two three shots that
was not kyle
now he's going back you know they tried
to make it seem like he was going back
to finish him off he's going to check on
him and then he gets chased away
and mr rosenbaum is laying face down
that's where he falls
richie mcginnis actually rolls him over
after trying to stem the bleeding here
you can see in the foreground that
plastic bag you just hear the judge's
phone start playing through
the bridge
come on oh i'm sorry sorry about that
that's inopportune
you can see the plastic
there's like american beauty it looks
like it's dancing objections argument
and uh you'll be allowed oh is that the
pedophile yeah
man you can see in this video because
it's attempting to
say
rosenbaum's life
i mean you know uh
am i the only one who says it's not as
sad as if that were kyle which is
exactly what it would have been no i
couldn't agree with that i don't feel
the same way i mean uh i don't know i
mean the guy raped five kids uh oh i
could i i feel worse for a dead squirrel
yeah i hit a squirrel the other day
about my car
because i tried to swerve and then he
swerved i did last stupid candy went
everywhere we have shown you
the defendant murdering joseph rosenbaum
is he allowed to say murder
objections
i don't know i thought he wasn't allowed
to he can i guess in closing arguments
no even in the trial he can accuse the
senator
that's what they're doing during this
entire incident he knew that joseph
rosenbaum was unarmed no he didn't
yeah back to this in a little while but
there's this alleged threat if you're
going to say that he knew he was unarmed
then you would have to allow for the
possibility that he knows he was a
pedophile of the defendant or do you say
well it's not relevant because he didn't
know he was a pedophile there's no way
he could have known he wasn't happening
yeah right in other words they expect
cal written house to be a mind reader in
one scenario and not in the other
whereas he was probably chanting from
the rooftops that he was burning down
that he was a pedophile like the rikala
guy i raped a kid
i ran five kids there's also no evidence
that it was his catchphrase it was yeah
i was like what you talking about
what you talking about kid who i haven't
yet to rape but i promise i will
eventually he owned the bike store he
just said there's no evidence that the
defendant was trying to take his gun
there was no evidence that he wanted his
gun what about the burn marks yeah can
someone bring that up in the control
room there the burn marks there uh from
uh i know uh
i think it was huber had burn marks
several of them had burn marks or had
what would that even have to do with
attacking someone though
it doesn't even matter if they wanted
his gun in my opinion no no if they're
attacking him and stomping him and
hitting him with stuff what does it
matter what they wanted to take i mean i
think at that point once they've been
setting fires
uh enough cause for shooting is if they
have an erection
exactly well we all know who does which
goes through
hand
and shift and then
and schumer raises the right scalp and
one that goes right into mr rosenbaum's
back
and that and rosenbaum every time he
went well he's saying
he's also saying that he's i mean he's
just like any time a chucky cheese
commercial came on yeah while he was
watching nickelodeon there is no
evidence we have a punching bag here mr
rosenbaum i need to take out some anger
uh no but i think there might be a
pedophile ward down the street i thought
that one by the hour
i thought that was you well that's
normally the case he's saying that he
shot him in the back and uh mr rosenbaum
didn't pose a threat after the first
shot do you remember how fast that
happened
yeah no and by the way no one is even
arguing that he shot him in the back
execution
but he's saying he's trying to apply it
now that's what killed them no that's
not even an argument just so you know
for people who haven't been paying
attention to the trauma they go what he
shot him in the back it was four shots i
believe one two three four and the one
kind of went through his shoulder blade
because the pedophile was going and
killing mr rosen like that yeah yeah you
shoot to stop by the way you don't shoot
like he was catching a football going
long only it was bullets
there's been a lot of testimony about
this wound
this is one in which
the evidence suggests
that
mr rosenbaum's hand that you're going to
most likely are you doing a magic trick
palms outward with his thumb to the
ground this pencil is
the bullet goes through he's got a thumb
tip the area in between his middle
finger and his ring finger mr
rittenhouse is this your card the middle
finger and the index finger before
exiting
dr kelly testified their soot in that
area suggesting that the hand was close
but there you go okay there you go you
just said he wasn't even arms like okay
we don't even need to bring that up from
the control room
there was a bullet that went through his
hand and there was soot from the end of
the barrel
which we don't think is relevant first
of all this occurs this guy always ruins
his everything
i've got a fractured pelvis at that i'm
going to disprove what i've just told
you he is not able to walk he's probably
not even able to control much of his
movements at this point
what when you're reaching all happened
in like
one second to two seconds you're gonna
do it yeah you don't have time to go oh
now i can't move my pelvis
effective
i submit to you later no one's saying
he's the world's best pedophile gun
grabber we're just saying that he was
trying he's like completely inadvertent
he might be in the top five
he's saying that it was not intentional
that his hand was touching the gun now
it's irrelevant if his hand could touch
the gun
he wasn't trying to grab the little
boy's penis
it was just it was falling over
you're honored due to the psychotropic
medication
mr rosenbaum the pedophile yes
was on his depth perception was skewed
and he would not have been a threat in
attempting to uh grab kyle's rifle which
is why he grabbed it with his third
knuckle as opposed to as you know you're
uh you know grabbing it like a pinch of
dip which is how you would usually grab
a rifle i think the evidence speaks for
itself and uh uh we should win
i think we've proven that if he wants
something he just touches it yes and he
reaches out and touches it you can't
kill joseph rosenbaum for something
joshua zaminski did of course not so
let's just carve joshua
no no no no no convenience
but god can hold on but until then you
do not get to carve after that you're
releasing from jail that day today's a
good day for you to get out
the zaminski's continue walking straight
on down the sidewalk they don't pursue
the defendant they don't threaten the
defendant in any way
this is more accurate the commentary
that we're providing
that guy's full of crap
yeah they were hitting him with a
skateboard yes he wants skinner to go
they were asking him if he wanted to go
skating dave oh that's true by hitting
him in the face
you don't bring a gun to a fist fight
well you don't bring gas bombs to a fist
fight either and once you light a few
dumpsters on fire and push them into the
petrol station i think you look behind
you there's the fish fight you've got
you've got a little past fist fight at
that point not to mention he also had a
chain frozen bomb hey big old heavy ass
jane yeah well what fist fight the other
guy brought a gun to his bicep fight
that's murder like no he was just trying
to arm wrestle like over the top
reference here yeah you're gonna be the
best the only difference is talk about a
weird movie no no
he just said this is like a bar fight
where two guys are punching each other
and one guy punches knocks the other guy
out and gets on the ground and chokes
him out i think is what he said choke
him out he said that's murder you can't
do that he goes well what's the
difference here the only difference is
cal brought again i'm like no
kyle was being pursued by somebody who
said he was going to get him his buddy
had a gun kyle knew that that's what
started this whole thing that gun goes
off whether kyle thought that zaminski
was right there or not doesn't matter
rosenbaum's closing the distance
previously told that he was going to
kill his ass that's like rosenbaum's
attorney and the other
convictions being like oh your honor
what's the difference between this in a
bar fight uh he was raping a child in
the nursery well tomato tomato
unbelievable potato potato friend man
well also was the bar i don't know on
fire and being looted and just trying to
help when you're the one who brought
your gun so deadly force is never
appropriate when somebody is unarmed is
what he's saying never oh okay so women
hope you all like being raped sorry hope
you all like being raped because here's
the truth women you will never be able
to fight off a bigger stronger male
rapist especially if he's on pcp your
only chance is a gun this guy thinks
that you should uh go ahead and take
your nice good raping
just to be clear
just to be clear there's a reason that
firearms exist it's so that the old the
infirm
women when being sexually attacked by
men can protect themselves and yes for a
17 year old kid to be able to protect
himself against almost a mob of people
parallel to the ground he is almost face
first to the ground
the defendant fires a round into his
upper back
which is the kill shot
and another round which gazes grazes his
right scalp
at this point as you saw in that video
back resulted in sort of a cross fade
really
south is literally right across the
street and this crowd
except for the defendant
are all focused on trying to save you
you know washington's life because the
crowd attacks him yeah the crowd attacks
minutes later
yeah because that's what
just a cup maybe maybe a minute later
richie mcginnis testified
i rode with rosenbaum in the back of
that suv i told him
we'd have a beer together
and this is all done
they never got to have that heroes and
bomb was unable to restore then he found
out ah that's what he did mr roosevelt
was unable to respond um also it should
be noted that he was court-ordered to
not drink
uh because he raped children but uh
he said he would prefer a six-pack of
mike's heart that was his decision to
bring to an episode of to catch a
predator and instead he just brought
baby formula we don't know why he
doesn't get a pass
by pulling the trigger fast
yes he does have chosen to stop after
the first okay
hold on second shot what self-defense
class have you taken where they say just
only shoot once you shoot until the
threat is stopped yes again your right
to self-defense is on trial here yeah he
wants to say hey you shouldn't ever be
able to use a gun unless the other
person has a gun okay so if someone
comes into your house in the middle of
the night if something can't use a gun
you don't know if that person has a gun
or not guess what if the person turns
out to be unarmed you're done
your life is over if a man is raping you
you're a woman he doesn't have a gun you
use a gun guess what this guy thinks
your life should be over if in this
scenario these
the point is this is not the reason for
you to be able to carry a gun it's
specifically so that you don't have to
suffer undue harm not so that you suffer
just enough to go tit-for-tat that's not
the point no stop you shoot to stop he
goes the defendant fired all four shots
in .76 seconds well and then he goes and
he doesn't he doesn't get a pass for
being fast i'm like
you just said no he gets a reward well
he fired it in 0.76 seconds how could he
possibly have known that the threat was
neutralized yeah he couldn't he thinks
it's red dead he thinks he can like
target exactly what he wants and then
shoot yeah unbelievable i mean i hope
the jury is picking up on this i hope
the jury is shaking their heads like
this guy's an [ __ ] you're scared you
have to be anyway to shoot somebody yeah
especially at that age like just hand
shaking afraid
and it's very clear he tried to avoid it
yeah as long as he could yeah i mean i
think the fact that he turned aimed the
gun said okay and then turned back that
again makes his case even more he only
shot him once he had heard a gunshot
turned around and the guy was close
enough to grab his barrel and have soot
burn wounds
he had nowhere left to couldn't have
been in other words i don't think that
you should i think you should be able to
stand your ground
i think that cal right now should be
able to stand there with a fire
extinguisher say i'm putting out this
fire and the guys say i'm gonna kill you
and the second he gets right up to him
bang bang bang i think that's how it
works that's how the law reads and stand
your ground states you shouldn't have to
run away until you reach a barricade and
you have a ghost pedophile shirtless
with a raging erection you shouldn't
have to wait to that point to exercise
your god-given right to defend your life
or the life of your wife or your
children by the way
does anyone know well since he's
speculating right now since everything
he's saying is just entirely it's
entirely an inference do you think any
one of them would have cared if you said
hey there's a kid in that car source uh
front office no no
they would be celebrating his death
right now if it wasn't the fact that he
brought in he didn't have to choose
where to run
he chose to run in between those parked
cars he was running away he slows down
because there's a crowd you mother the
crowd father sister running away you
know the defense wants to make a point
there's a whole bunch of people over
there there are there running away
because zaminsky fired no escape round
into the air the defense wants to use
evidence and video
video foundation
i think come on
dna forensics right by the way bring up
their past zaminski fired his weapon
have charges been filed on him for
illegally firing or discharged how about
gage gross
i'm not even we'll get to that one he
just admitted multiple times that he
fired that shot have you filed charges
against him d.a and by the way assistant
from what we understand he fired the
shot in the air
oh yeah could have been an old lady on
her porch yeah watching the fire from
afar drinking the mike's hard lemonade
yeah then she just got hit with a stray
nine millimeter
we're gonna have a beer like it's the
end of a war movie yeah he's gonna
they're gonna take a dead pedophile with
a rag over his head
he said they're having technical
difficulties uh and uh twenty-five what
is a different thing to say they're
about to go to lunch it's a dead
pedophile with a rag hey
hey hey hey don't you quit on me don't
you quit on me you'll be raping kids
before you know it look at this look at
this we're gonna be in a sunset making a
boat with kids in the hall
the whole time he's uh
he's naming uh different different
positions like bubba and forrest gump
so they're pausing for i think a
45-minute break there can be a reverse
cow miner
look here's a picture of my cousin look
at it there's uh there's 69 when they're
six and nine
it's all definitely terrible stuff
oh my gosh let's see what they say and
cnn real quick well i mean he's doing
something that the judge didn't do which
is uh speaking in a way that people can
generally understand
i find that until they see what he's
discussing they're like wait that that
clip
is kind of implausible on its face i
mean he's really saying
that you know rosenbaum
first of all never threatened to kill we
haven't heard the basis of that that's a
lady on the right her eyes are really
close together they've said that yeah
i feel like generously i feel like she'd
be easy to flank and paintball that uh
cut somebody's heart out it was close oh
wow yeah
so we'll have to hear what he says in
his summation
her dad's a doberman pinscher adding
that this chase
that caused whitney house to run
should not be placed uh written down in
fear of his life and he makes a big deal
about him running scooch over a little
bit yeah a little out of frame yeah look
at john kane just sitting there looking
like the uh the guy in toy soldiers
got to go
about to go mess up some garner nuts
the other thing is you should just be
chewing on part of a cigar toy soldiers
are small soldiers also small soldiers
but i could totally get what you meant
it was more fun than it got credit for
yeah you know so is toy soldiers that
was the uh the academy one where they're
all uh like with sean aston and they get
their
boys school gets taken over by
terrorists oh yeah yeah
oh it's great yeah yeah perhaps taps
that was also taps i have no idea what
you're talking about but that's uh they
actually think this guy did a good job
on cnn this just goes to show you the
gas line right now they don't want you
to believe what you saw yeah they don't
want you to believe what is available
this is how this guy on cnn is never
getting invited back because he's
defending and saying actually this is
going to be really hard he's making a
big deal of the secret it's not
plausible that's not plausible like that
kyle wasn't in fear for his house i want
to hear what he said okay let's hear
yeah beginning here mr bringer has
another hour or so to go he said at the
top then the defense obviously makes its
closing argument and then the
prosecutors get time to rebut but right
out of the box you hear mr bringer the
facts are not in dispute here in many
cases the facts aren't dispute the basic
facts are not in dispute here mr
rittenhouse acknowledges pulling the
trigger uh two people died one was
wounded uh the whole issue here is
self-defense prosecutors tried to take
thank you cnn
he felt threatened he was under threat
so he was protecting himself uh grade
the prosecutor so far again with the
ways to go
is she going to speak in a basement and
also a keeper
not only do you like surprises that's a
provocation right that's that's right
the issue in this case whether or not
prosecutors would be even allowed to
argue about provocation which under
wisconsin essentially takes away that
self-defense claim it's a kind of a
tricky my right eye was once sammy davis
junior i really think um you know
commentators were saying that
i think he made a great case
big diamond pinky rings once i was
afraid i was petrified
mr bojangles any days for
uh the you sounded like a first-year law
student uh in a criminal oh no exactly
uh he had like a kind of a a stream of
consciousness uh talking it's called
it's called common sense it's called
grandpa of consciousness i know that's
foreign to you what with former vice
president biden on television all the
time he said he had a stream of
conscienceness and almost it's almost
like he's just talking like a regular
person and it isn't given like hers just
stopped mid-stream yeah she's a she's a
drawing of sean penn and
fast times
but just one half duplicated on the
other side they hit her cell phone off
the wall speaker
off in the courtroom when you're at the
most part are you an easter island head
[Laughter]
is it night at the wax museum and it's
half melted
is that just a you know
a confusing drama that didn't need to
play out my face yes it doesn't impact
the jury
it will impact the jury john and uh no
it really was there we go he scooted
into the middle of the frame judge
because
when they had had these extensive
discussions about the
charge i'm too old to go after superman
analyzing the charge and saying well
this element has to be explained this
way in this element we should discuss it
another way but it just fell apart when
he started presenting it to the jury and
there's a way to simplify it
eventually discovered which is kind of
important there potentially
and essentially stupid conduct it's when
he told the jury what happened
like it is he's saying the judge giving
instructions to the jury is when it all
fell apart oh i thought he said yeah the
guy delivering him it's all criticism of
the judge because he had gone on and
made you know some obviously racist
comments we've all we could all agree on
that right well i don't know an asian
food that's racist i know i can't call
it chinese food yeah i didn't call it
oriental food because you guys all make
a big stink about that just just food
sir i'm trying to do the right thing
here just food but it's asian food no i
mean isn't it is it not in the continent
of asia i don't know but i know i gotta
worry i gotta order and say no msg or
i'm gonna have a headache for a while
yeah uh you know i think the real
problem is your lunch wasn't jeez
there i used to see in here because of
the massage parlor but i think she aged
herself out yep you know like a nice
black a cheddar
i'm a big fan i love the cheese oh boy i
barely even put meat on my burger all
right just do a cheese
sometimes a sharp cheddar sometimes a
perm them cows are real heavy sometimes
both because i live on the edge the
point is the state of wisconsin
mr binger will not apologize for its
cheese
now if you'll excuse me i'll be taking a
nitroglycerin pill because i have four
heart attacks a day
as most people do from wisconsin it's
absolutely fair
what are these talking about here this
is how useless cnn is when they can't
just tell you the truth
i mean i don't know do we have any clips
or anything
you know what well yeah you have no let
me know from the chats what questions
you guys have right now might be a good
time for that yeah it might be a good
time to take some uh
we'll just take them from mug club but
chats of specific questions you have is
there any confusion left here
in this trial and by the way if you're
watching on rumble smash that rumble
button smash the like button on youtube
right now just make sure uh you you are
thorn in the side of youtube
because this is number one in their
trending streams
i don't understand the agenda of having
on these people on cnn where it's like
well we find a woman who obviously has
this you know certain way she's going to
look at this or we've
crossed i think we're going to just look
yeah no just look right there
yeah is there a way
i like to look at both sides of the
arguments but i can't
i'm always looking at both sides okay
outside a okay and then yeah i see what
he's saying too yeah i'm always seeing
oh i know about that they call it double
vision
but it's like you it almost feels like
she was coached yeah and i obviously we
can't say that for sure but this is with
the cnn
yeah and and then you have this other
guy
where
they're blaming the judge for somebody
else's closing arguments yeah of a
firearm he crossed the lines to come
into it's not true um you know a melee
really did she just say something took
it upon him
carefully he didn't say that he crossed
with a firearm by the way state lines
means nothing i lived in you know
someone who lives in michigan crossing
between michigan and illinois ohio there
are areas there where people it's you
can you can live in michigan work in
illinois or vice versa and it can be a
10-minute drive i was talking to my
buddy jimmy about that last night he's a
huge fan of you and uh he said the same
thing he's like it's it's monroe to
toledo if that right you know it doesn't
it's it's absurd yeah they want to make
it seem like he was
it shouldn't matter they don't believe
in borders so who cares right all of a
sudden now it's really important
borderline oh that's right that makes
sense they want to divide us internally
and they just want to make sure we have
no external borders it's almost like
it's part of some i don't know what some
great something yeah
but it sounds like some [ __ ] commie
gobbledygook i love it
yeah i've got a few questions okay also
um
what was it jared yeah garrett's michael
jackson video game is surprisingly
accurate his description it's kind of if
you want to see it it's pretty crazy
what am i going to look at it's a
game play
that's right like saving kids all that
stuff it's pretty wow yeah let me see
this don't see michael jackson's
moonwalker all right
the street level i told him
no no that's the chimp oh it's bubbles
okay dude i remember this i forgot this
existed i don't told y'all
but i got a point where there's ah
you'll never catch me for the
six-year-old yeah if it's a grown man
he's not chasing it for a reason
[Music]
come on
it's the greatest game i've ever seen
what's the final boss a dna sample
[Music]
look at the kickstarter the very last
thing
oh no it's a kid oh you in blueprints
for a ferris wheel
what is he throwing sparkles
oh
another
sparkles
micah
i don't want he's going through this
house finding children that are hiding
yes he's going through his own house
this was a cry for help he found a lady
and he was like nope yeah yeah no screw
that lady it's just a bunch of lights
are on fire it just looks like a bunch
of fbi agents trying to help stop it it
was captured stop catching the kids and
the sprinkles are basically don lemon
throwing his taint juice at them
where are you going get back here got
magic just
the goal of that game is to get the kids
back into the rooms before those grown
men in suits can get you
that's the greatest game how did we not
see this oh my goodness it's hbo
gary you need to pick out every video
game for me
i've completely forgot that existence
you know it's just a beautiful eye for
help i certainly don't that's almost
like irony that's almost like when the
riddler starts leaving clues because he
wants to be caught yes yeah i bet you'll
never solve what i do on my own time
yeah
uh we have a video game to introduce
into evidence your honor it couldn't be
more incriminating if michael jackson
sent a ransom note with cut out letters
and magazines like i ramped all the kids
yeah well uh michael
you know the way we know this is your
magazine when you clip this letter out
you kept your address and name oh yeah
yeah you put your return address
yeah
it's that bottom left corner that always
gets you
yeah what if it was yes in the mail i
don't know how to pass stamps oh no oh
yeah also you uh when you mailed it you
also mailed the mad folding which uh
this issue was a corey heme but it's
stuck hmm no if my kids could just wear
eyes wide shut masks yeah that won't be
weird at all i call it a costume party
ballroom party every day but everyone
has to drink the puns
somebody's at the door cause i heard a
series of bells that lead to my bedroom
and that's not weird at all the only way
parents can get here and the senses not
go off as if they go through the lasers
like catherine zeta jones entrapment
that was gross she's disgusting oh this
paris hotel's all booked up but i got
your parents a nice room in ireland
northern ireland oh
they're gonna die
there's some nice people uh nice people
can take care of your parents ira
i better slow down you gotta moonwalk on
stage tomorrow
don't forget your pepsi commercials
sparkles whether it was hosting like a
fake pepsi commercial or something i
don't remember what no he he's hair lit
on fire i think it was a diet coke
commercial right was it pepsi or was it
i don't remember it might have been
pepsi here
yeah it was when he had the like the
kind of the jerry curl in the 80s yeah
and it just that stuff is flammable yeah
i mean you might wow is there footage of
that yeah well that's where uh yeah just
been wearing like an asbestos toupee
that's just going to go up
i want to see his hair that is actually
what little richard
for many years yeah
they say that's what turned him gay yes
it just burned singed the straight part
of the insulation wig
never gonna
oh
[Laughter]
and in no way do we believe that youtube
no no no no our choice of course
whatsoever no he was born in any
scenario he sang tutti frutti and
everybody nobody caught on
uh yes quick question your honor who's
rudy
and what is tutti frutti awning oh yeah
like you're doing
well help me understand tutti frutti is
what i prefer and rudy is a terrible
film yes
exactly
all right let's go to some questions
about because i don't know what
questions to answer this is speechless
it all seems pretty cut and dry i want
to hear what people think okay that's
more of it yes yeah so why why duke
wants to know what do you think is the
most damning evidence against kyle love
the show in no club
well i think it's um
i don't know i'm guessing if so the most
well i can't say most damning evidence
but the worst thing that could happen to
kyle is if someone comes in and
sprinkles dust on the jury and ask them
to think happy thing
and they never come back uh i'm trying
to think of the worst thing uh
i think you're right yeah that seems to
be about
oh
um oh i i have it uh he's white
that's true definitely the most damning
evidence that they're going to present
is that he's white it's called the
actually he's hispanic is he yeah
he's half hispanic apparently what is
so between him and zimmerman what is
with these white hispanics
yeah i don't know
i don't know that i mean that's that's
the only thing community
that's the only thing that i can speak
for myself yeah only the black mixed
community yeah there's really no
evidence against them honestly no and
and so even well i was going to say the
only thing i thought they could make
stick was the gun charge and that's gone
right and it's gone now that's just uh
that's a that's a really good sign well
they're also lying about the uh the the
order of events on the first part right
yeah with rosenbaum right they know that
they can't touch the next part right
because this is where he's defending his
life clearly with people who are armed
right well no i don't know i think he's
going to touch it
i think he's going to reach out and rose
and vomit because he's going to try yeah
he's going to because he tried to say
you only shot him for kicking you with
one foot
so they actually think this is a
compelling argument because the left
believes you have no right to
self-defense they believe you have the
right to protect yourself if the right
people in positions of authority and
government grant that right that's a
fundamental difference hey i ask again
who is the militia
according to the constitution
let's just be really clear about that
that's something and it's it's it's been
affirmed by the supreme court it's
well-known it's well documented it's
been offered by all of the all the
auxiliary documents the supporting
documents that you can read from the
founding fathers they're very very clear
there's a reason militia comma necessary
to the security of a free state comma
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms if they wanted only some term like
the militia meaning something separate
from the people they would have
clarified that they would have said the
right the right to the militia to keep
and bear arms they didn't they said a
militia being necessary and then they
they supported it when people were asked
yeah they they thought it was so absurd
like well who's the militia they're like
oh everyone's a militia take that guy
and send him on a boat how do you create
a militia unless everyone has guns they
do what i mean who's who's got the gun
otherwise you're just what are you just
talking about a military at that point
that's not a militia
no no no you can't ask for the guns no
it's too late at that point oh exactly
well so here's the timeline this folks
i mean if you need the guns and you
don't have the guns i mean you're kind
of screwed well we thought it was only
for the uh air force and navy and until
you see how it affects
real thongs
uh by the way that was that was
that was his argument that was a
prosecutor's argument he's like you
didn't need that gun like why'd you take
a gun with you to the riots and protests
and the things where things burned and
people got assaulted and guns were fired
why would you take a gun you don't need
it well i don't know i take a gun with
me um always yeah well he said he said i
was attacked he goes well yeah but still
it's been why why'd you have it i i do
love that he's pushing that where it's
like well i was worried that they were
going to try to hurt me and then they
did yeah i almost at this point want to
sell uh i think it would be a good idea
for you know so that there are no future
9 to 11 year old victims of the five
kids he raped
guns that look like nerf guns yeah yeah
i think they did yeah just so they could
shoot pedophiles they did they had a gun
that looked like i mean i know you'd
have to put it in the lock box whatever
but
yes of course i just think you know i'm
just look i'm not i'm not afraid
i don't care who just i don't care who
this offends okay i'll just be clear
because i know i'm gonna get a lot of
flack i uh i don't like uh child rapists
listen i look wow i don't care who it
looks don't say that well i'm sitting on
your show
and we're all gonna have to fall for
this
[Laughter]
by the way
did you see him fall before he died and
burned in hell yeah michael jealous yeah
right there yes of course yes michael
jackson welcome to pedophile hill
there's no boys here otherwise it's no
it's just being you
it's pretty much just earth without
children
[Laughter]
all we have are sports illustrator
models yep that's it yeah look and when
you open up there's okay up and standing
for all eternity
there's copies of boy's life when you
open it it's playboys i'm gonna get sick
i just threw up on the inside like
one but then you also have short-term
memory so you just keep doing it yeah
you just forget that you did it oh look
there's oh no
i want to look at old pictures of opie
ron howard when he was kathy ireland
[Laughter]
now rosenbaum picture your favorite
thing i know you can and your wiener's
gone
it's him i don't think he's gonna fire
him
all the booties are so shut
oh no no every now and then you think
you see a nine-year-old boy but it's
just satan doing one of his mirages
it turns around and it's a beautiful
woman the greatest the greatest trick
the devil ever pulled was making me
think that there was a nine-year-old
oh my gosh i mean really i know by the
way just for everybody out there right
now we they are on a break if you're
watching us don't go anywhere they're
not 40 they're on a break i'm going to
break we're still watching nothing's
going on yet when they come back i think
i want to be here they're having some
asian food we're having some
they're waiting on it from that boat in
the harbor waiting for the boat in the
harbor yeah so you know listen we didn't
want to have any more fiascos with the
asian food so uh you know we got some uh
some of that [ __ ] food some of that
yeah bat soup wasn't sitting too well i
hope none of those uh foods are chips
and they're on the boat in that harbor
i don't know boating a rio grande they
have boats yeah hopefully they're not
sneaking it over the border no i don't
know hello i'm hoping that they coyote
our food here fast something because i'm
hungry i got to tell you i looked at
cookie mouse i don't know is there food
is there is our latino food being put in
the back of a turtle by the cartel is
that what it is
you know slow and steady may win the
race but uh i'm hungry now
getting its heads and hands uh sewed off
and then hung over and overpass you know
ooh i don't know rough i don't know
you know what i guess i should just get
american fusion from now on yeah i think
everybody would agree a nice block of
cheddar nice block of cheddar maybe have
one of them burgers yeah a hot dog but
not one of them burgers from uh burger
king you know because that sticks on
your fingers for all time like uh later
after you still smell it like it's going
remember me
for the whole day like don lemon yeah
you know i mean ah you know that's the
problem is uh you know don lemon that's
what you know what they called them
they called them uh
double double don with cheese
yeah there was uh there's the dairy
queen and the burger king but i gotta
tell you the food don't taste too royal
no i don't taste that oil i don't think
the royal family has ever sampled their
menu i'll take the don lemon with uh
extra sauce please there you go i'll
take the don lemon with uh which is uh
you know that's just where the server uh
you know he just grabs his bowels and
[ __ ] jams them in your face
which i didn't know but it's policy over
there wow yeah can i uh can i get you
something he says can i get you
something off off the wine list and uh
he just grabs his kick
heavens you know but uh you know we're
all different turns out that's just how
he says i love you
that's how he says he cares you know put
that on a hallmark card just just a
smear of don lemon's tent juice
this is painful yes all right
let's go to some chat any other
questions about this i mean this one's
so open and shut
yeah it's yeah it is we've got
how is he gonna stretch it out i think
the other guy's gonna come out and just
go you guys you guys know this is
[ __ ] yeah and uh and i'm not gonna
wait i want the defense to come out and
just go to the jury go
and then body slam finger yeah
rip just a little wave they just shut up
they just like they're like what's going
on here the jury's in there's a there's
ropes and a turnbuckle and the fence
just comes out
[Laughter]
yeah there's a macho man right yes no i
got it yeah
wrestling is savage back when the uh the
vaughn eric i was a flare that was rick
flair i know was that rick flair yeah
oh his career is done
rick flick oh come on do you see that
thing that he did on the plane
what are you doing from hell oh all the
raping and stuff
sexual assault oh well he is a wrestler
i just assume all that comes with the
territory yeah hey rick uh just because
you're 36 000 feet in the air doesn't
mean you've like escaped the
jurisdiction okay that's still that's
why i like that american airspace i
think they should ring a hell though for
that reason because it's just like every
wrestler well that's what it is it was
the one about the flight from hell yeah
all on there so all right let me go to
the question that they have i don't know
what i'm trying to think i don't even
know where to go because every
everything this guy said is a lie yeah
all right danny lynch wants to know mr
crowder are you at all concerned that
the jury will convict simply on the fact
that they fear the mob actions that will
ensue that's why where i think the judge
needs to step in maybe right
so i elementary i have a directed
verdict at that point because you could
certainly make an argument for a
mistrial with prejudice because of jury
intimidation there's someone there
filming them yeah i i think this one has
been a little bit better than uh than
what we saw with chaven's trial yeah
because we we knew for a fact because
you know maxine
all out there saying uh we're gonna burn
this place down if you don't vote our
way on this um but i'm just gonna pass
over that as if it didn't happen just
continue
but in this case it's i mean there is
intimidation but i don't think it's been
quite as severe thankfully yeah
thankfully you should open with is uh
you see nothing the bing here says made
any sense just to give him nicknames
yeah
and well i'm not supposed to say this uh
if you vote not guilty free applebee's
so uh
do the right thing and have some
ramp artichoke tip spinach
i don't know do you boys like two for 20
appetizers i do
i like sex
i mean frankly i'd like sex without the
apple bees but i just thought i'd
lube you guys up a little bit first
i thought a sizzling skillet might get
you in the mood there was a guy you were
wrong there's a guy who
said hang around and appleton was
constant at a limo and he just thought
he was like some big shot which it's
like it's like 2010 you're not a big
shot you have an old limo but he's like
take it his nice place it's called
applebee's you're gonna love it you can
get almost anything you ever dreamed of
there it's a neighborhood bar and grill
oh they got they have a really really
expansive menu yeah and none of it's
good yeah you can get almost anything
that tastes like everything else yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah rose and mom's like
oh they have boys you said anything i
wanted yeah this [ __ ] always orders
off the kids menu what's his deal he's
always asking for curly straws and [ __ ]
i don't know we all have a thing do you
have a kid's menu not this kind
[Laughter]
it's more of a preference list yes sir
you must leave it i don't know what
question what no i don't think what was
this question
no i think they're going to be
intimidated
jury can be intimidated and i think
that's where you need a directed uh
directed verdict if it's clear i mean i
don't know we can look up the directed
verdict but i'm not sure
when the judge is allowed to step in in
that case for a directed verdict
i don't i think in this case there's
already enough in other words i think
he's holding it in his back pocket the
mistrial with prejudice i don't know i'm
not a lawyer i don't know exactly how it
works but i think there's more than
enough at this point with the jury
intimidation with the fact that he
brought up that
you know that kyle was uh
invoking his fifth amendment right which
is well established you know legal
precedent in this country that a
prosecutor is not supposed to be right
bringing that up against uh the defense
so i think there's there's enough there
at this point yeah but he's i think he's
already passed the point where he would
do something like that you don't let it
go to the jury if you're going to
declare a mistrial because nothing new
has happened for him to declare that he
already had that he took it under
advisement unless littlebinger brings
something out well it says something
crazy different right if new things come
out then yeah he could do that but it
looks like he thinks right now he's
adjusting his fauxhawk
yeah he's
he's in the mirror right now like am i
like am i on every news station you say
they love me out there oh yes
i'm doing a bang-up job
mother said you'd never make it but you
made it big
left you in the attic for a long time
you never
you never came for me mother all right
let's go to another chat
this is um
and by the way for people who are
watching right now on youtube we usually
take these chats on on mug club yes mug
club a lot of people are wondering like
a mug club like obviously we're just
doing this we'll extend the uh the
segment today on the trial but our mod
club we'll do full segments games and we
only take chat exclusively on mug club
yeah so we actually know a lot of the
people who chat yeah no it's way too
much we know you're crazy every once in
a
while
every now and then
all right so this one's from tyler fair
and i'm not exactly sure what the
question is but he pointed out something
interesting is binge possible communist
uh communist lapel pin being used in
giving ridden house an appeal if somehow
he was convicted of any charge does he
have a communist lapel i i i've heard
people talk about it but like
everybody's actually sick
i don't know i think it might be like a
joke about he's a star wars nerd because
he has like the rip he like he wore this
on november 8th that means the rebel
alliance
yeah this is the rebel alliance oh yeah
it is star wars he had
i think that's just star wars yeah
he's got a millennium falcon here oh
yeah he's just a star wars he's just a
nerd well he just came but that's
actually star wars millennium film no
he's just on the dark side
what's his name to come in and his tie
is going to be hanging die
just comes instead of a tie is that
sorry
dream catcher
gosh his uh jedi looks [ __ ] guilty yes
unworkable
those are the defendants you're looking
for no what oh well bingo if i have to
call the jury out one more time because
you're star wars [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that let's leave it right there yeah
it's nope nope and then han solo i mean
mr rosenbaum i'm sorry your honor i
i confuse my heroes in movies all the
time
[Laughter]
i told you you can't move my gavel stop
stop trying
you're not going to melt my head crying
out loud
judge starts doing it back this is a
circus
your honor i brought rosenbaum back from
the dead
here he is
yeah you choking on asian food now your
honor
all right let's grab another chat i
guess i don't know look i mean if we
have so many other clips key witnesses
there's just there's nothing there's
nothing for the defense for the the
prosecution to bring up at this point
look at it look i don't know if you guys
can see this i've got all this stuff
here but but the truth is
none of it matters
it doesn't matter none of that is
feuding any of it he's like he because i
thought i was ready to refute right the
second time he's done this to us this
actually happened earlier for people who
are tuning in now or weren't here
earlier yeah he said uh he's not even
within arm's arms length when
kyle rittenhouse shoots him talking
about the serial rapist pedophile and i
said hey bring it up in the control room
i'm pretty sure they had like soot marks
or burn wounds and then 30 seconds later
he goes now he was shot through this
knuckle and this knuckle and in fact had
soot marks
proving that it was not the most
effective way well to grab a rifle if
you wanted to you're not gonna grab a
rifle like this yeah you know i mean who
would do that yeah well certainly not
close range i think we all can agree on
it yeah no absolutely
because everybody does exactly what they
mean to when they're trying to chase
down and kill a 17 year old boy right
you're reaching out for the gun the
gun's moving your hands i mean come on
it's possible this is just muscle memory
he was reaching out like it was a
four-year-old that's true well and for
everybody you know everything is uh
completely thought out fully in a moment
of panic and terror especially when you
slow down the footage oh yeah stop
saying a moment of panic and terror
because
you know you're not supposed to get all
mushy oh i don't know touchy feely it
just well
i won't
remember you rose and rome all right
matthew bowen wants you to make a
prediction kyle gets cleared of all
charges what does the biden admin
respond with when asked
[Music]
you mean four hours yeah every response
is gonna be a four hour fart yeah
four hours after he takes 17 imodium
yeah
by the way this might be a perfect time
so many people probably weren't tuned in
when we started the show what do you
think it'd be a nice time to replay that
beautiful song that's still stuck in my
head on uh on that note uh do you have
to take a dump no i don't
all right what okay so yes okay you know
this is a perfect time to replay that
song so uh really quickly because we
might need to take a quick bathroom
break uh and we're going to continue but
yes what do i think i think they want to
run and hide and i'm not joking
i think he could soil himself yeah
as a matter of fact i think it's more
likely than not yeah and uh for proof
because i come with receipts uh here's
of course the new i thought it was just
i thought it was odd that the white
house released this as they're so weird
and i thought it was weird that uh
colombia worked with them yeah a white
house christmas here is the white
house's uh latest single uh
uh poop
[Music]
[Applause]
haha i always thought that a press like
me could squeeze and hold it in my
cheeks like a turtle pink we please the
masses but clenching it in our ass is
tijuana mexico holiness to tokyo people
know me though i swear my cheeks always
work it's like i'm bout to give birth
unexpected fun oh you heard kamala heard
she said it smell like dead crowd i
tried to blend the dog but it was on its
way out
i didn't know what i was trying to say
it's all right
i never know the time of the day
it's all right
oh
[Music]
man i need a towel
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's childish but it is
fantastic it's first class it is very
well done
and that is probably going to be his
response to most situations uh of import
uh dave by the way
a lot of people watching right now just
want to segue into yes you're
you're having a memorial service aren't
you yes i am no no dave's uh dave's
going to be in naples florida this
weekend yes off the hook comedy club
this weekend i should probably tell them
put off the hook on there naples florida
that would have been helpful 19th and
20th
uh come out this weekend we got three
shows saturday one show friday it's
gonna be fun nice and it's uh yeah it's
off the hook and it's uh near the water
you can celebrate uh kyle rittenhouse
being found not guilty
yes yeah it's gonna be off the hook this
will probably be in a part of the
country that isn't burning so it's gonna
be pretty exciting if you want to come
out i'm you know and speaking of that
i'm not 100 sure how this is going to go
i know the media has done everything in
their power to make kyle rittenhouse
look like he is a white supremacist and
make this an issue that you should go
out in the streets and march i know
kenosha is having some issues chicago
outside of that i mean maybe la maybe it
seems mild places i don't feel like this
is going to be a nationwide kind of
outcry chicago may be yeah i i don't
think it will be a nation uh national
outcry the problem is is there are a lot
of people who
have the information and will not
believe anything else
so there's so many people that believe
he is
a guy who just gunned down black people
which couldn't be further from the truth
all those people are on twitter i don't
know if i've ever met anybody like you
know but real life i know one guy for
real where i'm like why are you doing
this
like just watch there really is a silver
lining though in this and and what i
mean by that the people who
refuse to believe they're lying eyes and
ears right those people and this is
actually
so i've talked about this before i
talked about in the mission statement
before change my mind existed i pitched
this book and it was called american
idiots because green day was big at that
time only and the cover of the book was
like you know green day had the bleeding
heart grenade yeah yeah and i switched
it to a brain
and this was before the term social
justice warrior existed i used to refer
to them as american idiots the people
who just sort of decide to go along with
whatever is seen as progressive because
that's what the media that's what the
entertainment industry that's what
everything they every college professor
tells them to believe and i wrote about
and this is a part of changed my mind
and you'll notice how sometimes we'll
have really short segments with change
my mind and some will go really long
that's because i've always said one of
the most valuable skills is in
identifying and at this point there were
no terms that existed like social
justice warriors but i talked about
american leftists or um sorry american
leftist progressive leftist people who
are so bought in you cannot change their
mind you can't convince them and then
they're the american idiots who just
sort of go along with what they've been
told and a lot of them can be awakened
you know before the term red pill exists
and i said a big valuable skill is
learning the difference the socratic
method is how you speak with someone who
maybe has sort of taken their position
by default and when you have someone
like your friend who you're talking
about there dave what you need to do is
make an example of them for all of the
other people to see and i will say with
this there have been a ton
of liberals saying
i thought before i actually tuned in
that he had shot black people or i
thought that he was chasing somebody
this has really opened my eyes this is
something that is so clear that's why
the media hasn't really been covering it
day to day keep in mind even those on
the right weren't covering it day to day
fox news was not covering it we covered
it the very first day and then we did
updates every single day and then the
fox news decided okay now it's time to
start covering it we covered it from the
beginning because i think it's important
not because it was popular but because
i've always thought that it was
important and there are a lot of people
out there right now who are saying okay
i see this i've been lied to and the
left has pushed so far and they're
continuing to push as you're seeing on
cnn look bring this lady up right now
and i will tell you she is pushing
people to the right let's hear what she
has to say i haven't even heard her i
guarantee it legitimately any argument
he could make so to the extent
optimistic about trying to challenge
this is on bannon oh it's on bannon okay
understand anyway let me know if she
brings up my name
what you're going to see hmm is plenty
it's odd though that they would change
the subject yeah on a day like today
after the absolute plowing that the
prosecution gave itself yeah they're
like we gotta talk about something else
yeah this is uh
oh now they're talking about alex jones
and sandy hook anything anything but the
cal written house so how stressed i i
guess we could talk about that for a
second let me finish the point
but the point that i'm making here is
it's pushing a lot of people to the
right who have ears to hear they're not
going to cnn has to dig its heels in
brian stelter has to dig his heels in
msnbc right alex uh sorry alex alec
baldwin right the sean pens of the world
they have to dig their heels in but i
will tell you i've known a lot of people
a lot of people i will say it's a
relative of mine
was pretty progressive great person
once it came down to the vaccine mandate
once it came down to getting her kids
vaccinated however will never go back
it's just pushed too far yeah i know
people who thought the written house
saying oh he was there looking for
trouble and they've watched this trial
and said i can't believe they're trying
to they're basically trying to crucify
this kid yeah
and the fact that the left keeps pushing
in other words people look at the
independence look at how that has
changed dramatically look at women in
the suburbs with virginia look at how
that has changed dramatically when when
these things affect people in their
lives and i don't just mean their
pocketbook i don't just mean taxes i
mean critical race theory at school and
then the left says oh it's not really a
thing
yeah it is they know it is
when they experience wait a second
vaccine but i already had it i already
have natural immunity it doesn't matter
wait a second i don't want my kids to
get vacci it doesn't matter one size
fits all
when they see and americans innately see
they understand that the right to
self-defense is on trial they go ah in a
second you know he was being chased and
they said that they were going to kill
him and they hit him and they beat his
head and they're going oh he was asking
for it
there are a lot of people out there you
just don't hear about them in the media
that's what changed my mind is about and
i say this because i used to be on fox
news for a lot for four and a half years
then i appeared on cnn hl and i realized
this is just all we're doing is trying
to score points and you're actually
trying to run out the clock right it's a
four minute segment you want to take up
as much time as possible so you're not
trying to make the most effective points
brevity is not even taken into
consideration whereas with change my
mind it's okay most effective points or
do you get someone to start thinking
about their argument and the people who
you see the reason oftentimes people
think it's not that i'm incredibly
convincing
it's not that i'm a skilled debater it's
that we are talking with people on the
street sometimes on college campuses
sometimes not 50 to change my minds are
just in a street corner a lot of people
don't know that yeah it's because on
college campuses where you get the kids
who freak out the most but a lot of them
are just in some random corner in
vermont in texas in washington dc
and you see people change their minds
why because no one has spoken
with them about these issues yeah
had one story from the media and a lot
of people are willing to hear that's why
big tech has to get rid of any stories
that are positive about cal written
house that's why gofundme has to remove
anything that has to do with cal right
now that's why youtube has to get rid of
the dislike button because they know
that if this information gets in front
of people there will be a higher
percentage of conservatives in this
country than there were yesterday so
their
strategy
is to get as little information to
people as possible put it through the
gatekeepers now the gatekeepers lost
control with youtube with facebook with
twitter and now you're seeing that
consolidation of power again
because they don't want you to have
access look we provide all of our
references all of our sources a lot of
credit.com look at the link in the
description you may not like all of them
you may even think some of them are
being misinterpreted that's fine
but it's because we want you to do
research and i think with the cal
written house thing i think they
overplayed their hand and now they're
going we really shouldn't be playing
this trial because if people watch this
trial
they become more conservative yeah
absolutely and then we talked about it i
don't know that court tv was doing
anything nefarious they were bleeping
out parts of it and you made a really
good point like no the american people
need to understand what's being said
here because it's material now they let
the jurors hear it obviously but the
american people need to understand that
this guy was saying shoot me shoot me
right saying the n-word each time he
said that yeah right you need to
understand that that was really the
white supremacist shot the only guy who
was screaming the n-word at the top of
his legs
it was crazy enough that the black
people around him didn't do anything
like uh
he looked so nuts that they were like
i don't know i'd be saying that to be
like all right i'm gonna freeze right
here you see this six seven gentlemen
back here with a little bit more melanin
in his skin go huh and then go
all right i want to risk it you
understand why crazy beats big and black
every time every single time i mean
there's a there's a 17 year old kid on
trial right now for ruining a riot
yeah yeah think about it it's insane yep
well and rosenbaum probably talked about
it dead picnic am i right oh i mean i
don't mean to go in there talk about the
teddy bear picnic today's the day the
pedophiles have their picnic
that's all you can eat
ah
let's not
let's just
and you know what we want people to feel
guilty for
saying like uh you know what one dead
another dead five-time child rapist it
doesn't make me sad you may think you
think i'm an animal because it doesn't
make me as sad it doesn't make i am not
as sad as i would be if cal right now
we're dead i'm less sad that a man who
by the way this is just so people i'm
not said at all i'll just say yeah i
know everybody has a problem with that i
don't care no i don't care keep in mind
this is a guy who would date single
women so that he could sodomize their
sons yeah yeah this is what he would do
he would specifically seek out single
women single mothers yeah sing sorry
single mothers yeah yeah single not
single well it's so interesting he said
wow he paid for the women yeah single
birthing persons
single birthing person single birthing
person that's under five foot two yes
under five foot two preferably unarmed
and he would pick them so that he could
sodomize groom and sodomize their
children
just to be clear it's a kind of evil
that
i mean it doesn't really get much more
evil than that honestly no it really
doesn't
no no i mean
and we have to act like but this is the
problem of zero
killing an adult i'm sorry of course
you're killing it you're killing them
anyway when you do something like that
you're killing everything that makes
them innocent it just it's just so
disgusting in every way why would i care
and all the guy did was react in the way
that you think one of them would by
trying to chase someone down who's young
and hurt them yeah i do not care that he
was shot i don't care that he even knew
like i said if he was three thousand
feet away and picked him off from a
window and it just happened to be that
guy would have been like well
lucky guess
i don't and i don't want to lie in here
and if you say you can say that it's you
know
reveling in a death but it's not if you
don't revel in but why don't you revel
in the death of a pedophile
he's worthless yeah a worthless human
being
i don't know how that pedophile was not
in prison i don't either
saying letters he was convicted of
anally raping
a nine to 11 year old boy because there
are five convictions if i'm not mistaken
i think 11 charges five convictions i'm
not mistaken and they were not age 9 to
11 we don't know the specific details
but he at least anally raped sorry if
you have you shouldn't have kids
watching this because we're discussing
an actual trial right now um
at least one of them yeah
how is this man free yeah what kind of
system do we have that lets that people
say broken justice system what yeah you
know what i agree but not not because
it's systemically racist no no officers
are actually 16 times more likely to be
shot by a black man than a man shooting
an officer by the way i guess in this
scenario the color of the officer is
irrelevant because there's a higher
percentage of black officers and there
are the general percentage of the
population but they always talk about
this and that's not true but you know
what is true we have a broken justice
system if anyone can ever be found
guilty of raping a child and see the
light of day again as far as i'm
concerned yes
you're 100 right
kyle rittenhouse right now is facing
charges that are much more severe
than
raping a child
like i don't i understand like okay
you're talking about taking life as far
as a conviction as far as the time yeah
if he gets you know whatever time he's
going to get for this is going to be far
more than the child that is you know the
perpetrator that rapes the child
how is that i mean i understand the
differences in the crime but they should
be i mean maybe a day difference
like maybe yeah maybe the the child the
rapist doesn't get to get out uh you
know it serves a life sentence what it
effectively is a life sentence but
one day before murder well now what was
that person we were talking about who's
who's uh
who's a professor hey you guys can pull
it up uh i mentioned that just two days
ago uh minor attracted persons oh god i
saw that map but this person works at a
university yep it's like well we need to
destigmatize ah no okay if we're going
to destigmatize pedophilia what is
worthy of stigmatization honestly like
is there are we saying that nothing
should have stigma stigmatized the hell
out of pedophilia yes you should be
ashamed to walk into a crowd of people
because you think maybe somebody's going
to recognize your face from the bulletin
of pedophiles in your neighborhood yes
okay well if you're teaching a class
where you're trying to change the name
of it to sound culturally acceptable you
should i mean yeah just be arrested i'm
sorry yes yeah i'm up for i am 100 for
freedom of speech but that's not no
that's that's
that's in the minor citing correct
is that what we call a bullet catcher
yes yes
i've got a i've got a pretty good vile
i have a pretty wild video that i just
a lady who's defending rosenbaum and
well you can see wait what is this is
this like in the court she's a writer no
she no she she's outside i think she's
outside the courtroom and she's holding
a poster that has rosenberg
dressed as superman ah what
oh so let me see insane person with this
sign in particular uh you know you're
calling
uh joseph rosenbaum a hero
there's kind of been questions about why
you would call him a hero
six year olds in a single boundary since
he's a convicted sex offender sure
um so my answer to that is what it says
right here on august 25th 2020
they they were selfless heroes they
practice they could have saved they
could have saved dozens of lives what i
would never jump in front of a guy with
an ar-15 strap down and so they were
heroes and i'm sick and tired of
everybody making like they you know like
they deserve to die they were good for
nothing they were useless no they
weren't all all correct they were
unbelievably brave courageous
indivisible individuals so so so nothing
about his uh past criminal sex paper
about what happened on this date and you
know what else he's not here anymore so
why do we why do we why do we even have
to bring all that up
because it's relevant because the kids
he raped are yeah why didn't you exactly
i don't think superman raped any kids
superman look maybe just have super map
maybe two of them could just be superman
yeah
well we'll let that slide i guess yeah
you know one just put a knife to his
girlfriend's throat yeah you know
firearm uh
violations the other one's a commie i
don't know honestly i feel like lex
luthor
would look like superman in the face of
a child rapist yeah that's true you'd be
like oh boy i just wanted to take over
the world i didn't want to ah
well that that lady is also
insane well yeah so that's kind of the
problem she's like well i wouldn't jump
in front of an ar-15 yeah yeah they
didn't really either they were kicking
him yeah but you know what else uh that
lady is no more insane than rosenbaum
i've got another one for you and this is
not even a same lady this is not an
insane lady this is ben and jerry's oh
yeah hashtag ridden house trial displays
yet again that our justice system is
racist how would this trial be going if
he was a black 17 year old that crossed
state lines illegally carrying an air 15
and shot three white protesters we need
real justice in the legal system this
isn't it hey you know what can you bring
up that shooting that took place in fort
worth where the guy shot three kids at
school was a black kid yeah he shot uh
he shot a kid he shot a teacher and then
the bullet graced somebody else we were
covering it live he knocked over a
pregnant lady in knocked over a pregnant
lady the guy didn't get anything the guy
didn't even get a slap on the wrist the
guy didn't get his slap on the wrist
with a wrist slap bracelet you know that
goes like
oh
there's this bracelet those are funny i
used to get them when i would go to
chuck e cheese because that's all the oh
that's all the tickets could get me you
know ben and jerry's i'm glad you
brought that up i had to lean in my
monitors down here and it's a little
small i wanted to make sure i'm assuming
that they tweeted that out months and
months and months ago before we realized
that he actually didn't cross state
lines with a weapon
it was november 11th
they tweeted it out four days ago
because they couldn't be bothered to do
research they have to make crappy ice
cream right and support every little
liberal cause they can think and they're
releasing a new flavor pedophile swirl
it's delightful and it's just a picture
of a boy and you open it up yeah and
it's just uh it's got little sour patch
what is it we had rudy tooty unjustified
shooty yeah tooty unjustified shooty
justified this is a justified this is uh
just this is justified shooting yeah
this is
this is three scoops of justified
shooting do you think that uh ben and
jerry see the irony at all that uh they
were not they not only are acting as
propaganda right now but they were
likely the tool that joseph rosenbaum
used to lure the children into his gym
that's crazy yeah i got some chunky
monkey this is your i got some americone
dream colbert sucks get in the car
i got some corey hey miss anus oh geez
oh famous anus little chunks of
chocolate in there little christie you
make good cookies little pieces of
charlie shane in a sense
tiger piss
or blood blood piss whatever wow he's
insane if you google the lucas story
you'll know what i'm talking about it
involves frisco all right so i have a
legitimate question here or the ice
cream has crisco yeah thank you uh a
comment i will not stop so huber
on using her logic day of huber's the
only guy that i know of in that scenario
that that we could say
possibly did think that kyle was a
threat and was trying he was hitting him
with a skateboard yeah i think so right
so he didn't have like the guy running
up on him you know the the bicep guy uh
gage he knew kyle said he was running to
get to the police so yeah okay that
guy's out of the equation um the guys
that are running up and just hitting him
in the back of the head when he's
running down the street those are kind
of it's kind of 50 50. if you think it's
an active shooter it's a dumb thing to
do yeah but i understand yeah most of
the time
you don't run no
run away but huber's the only guy that
you could say that if he just happened
to be wrong hubert could would have been
lied to by uh by gage right then get him
get him you know get him you could who
was knowingly lying right but nobody
else has any claim right no one else in
this scenario certainly not wrong and
even then it doesn't change the fact
that it's still self-defense no it's
still self-defense i'm just saying like
if you could say okay well this guy was
trying to do something honorable none of
them were except for possibly that guy
yeah no i'll give you that i mean i i
i'm not even sure that's true he may
have known and not cared right no but
you're saying it is something that could
i mean it could be insane
yeah it is conceivable it's possible
it's still self-defense it's still
self-defense it doesn't change at all
just because he thought he was doing
something good and wasn't right doesn't
mean that kyle has to go oh he thought
it was oh you thought it was a mass
shooter and just get how long does that
mean freaking lunch
they were crying out loud how many
mesotheliomas commercials i have to
watch
45 minutes
are they coming back now it no no no
that's from before it's from this
morning they keep
footage oh this is painful yeah it
really is ridiculous just get your asian
food it's on that truck why is it taking
so much time to get here
at the port yeah he's got his own ports
there in wisconsin bus terminal i'm just
trying to see if there's anything else
that i need to bring up as far as clips
or key witnesses well i don't
yeah you show their smoking gun which
only favor the pro or the defense oh
wait is this oh this is astro world yeah
what is this tough to tell the
difference between that and kenosha when
you're looking at it oh and those people
oh yeah that nine-year-old just now did
they find out if there were people
actually stabbing with fentanyl yeah i
have no idea yeah they've never heard
anymore that i had heard they were using
super fentanyl because when fentanyl
just won't get the job done yeah make
sure you use
superfine yeah you need super fentanyl
i don't know i didn't even know that was
a thing but know that what mad scientist
is making that they're like it's a two
yeah it's super i just feel like it
happened by accident
you'll be so high and dead and dead at
the same time george floyd might have
been a contestant for that one he may
have wanted to
he was into fentanyl yeah
they had me on ketamine and fentanyl i
was like whoa
i get it hey
i get it and you're saying it's cheap
sold
well and you get the best
yeah whenever you get a hospital drug
you're like oh man
that is it
but the problem is i have i am what uh
they call it
ultra rapid metabolizer so it would be
like they could only give it to me every
four hours they started getting dilaudid
when i was in the bed
yeah i don't know they're gonna be
delighted to give me fentanyl morphine
but then it would be gone within two
hours you don't get hangovers just
tombstone i've i've i've never really
had a hangover but i don't drink a ton i
drink consistently but i don't i don't
really drink to get drunk i'll only
drink something if i enjoy it so i'm
sure if i went out with the mission to
get drunk it'd be a little bit different
but no i don't really get
the only thing that really messes me up
is benadryl
okay and then flexural the muscle
boy i just i get behind a wheel yeah
benadryl just leaves me groggy for like
a day and a half there are certain
things but that there are other drugs
that just
any pain medication any stimulant i can
just go well and you have you know metal
in your chest and they're like there's
uh two vicodin and some no they gave me
for a week then they're like
nothing i couldn't believe that we've
gone way too far the other way that's
the problem now of course because of you
know people like the george floyd's out
there who abuse it and then it's like
you have people who are actually in a
hospital who've had major surgery and
they can't get anything yeah or small
town doctors with loose prescription
pads because they want to keep their
businesses afloat yeah as i call them
what uh so regarding rosenbaum um this
was from snoops so he he was sentenced
to that age mr rosenbaum mr rosenbaum
they call me mr child rapist
he was sentenced at age 19 and he did
serve uh 15 years in prison i think he
got out in 2017. oh wow well that's not
enough nope no
15 that's all you get 15 years he was 19
years old and he raped a nine-year-old
ages nine to 11 five children um
arizona's pima county uh he showed them
porn he did a lot of gross stuff
yeah well i think worse than the porn is
the anal rape yeah yes it can be there
is yeah oral oral sex he performed oral
sex on the molested them
throw him away
15 years and that never gets out is that
what that woman meant when she said he
was entirely selfless she performed she
thought he was a selfless lover
i can't i don't know the point is i'm
trying to get into the mind of a leftist
today like the cell
yeah no you don't want you don't want to
go into his dream world it's just please
like me my husband's fun here
the other kind of crazy thing is um that
article said that the community was
really worried that he would um rape
again do it again yeah like michael
myers returned to the house of the
original raping
while he was in prison he had he had 40
infractions yeah what was the
information i'm sorry 40 what it's it's
things like assault on staff uh
possessed drugs or narcotics arson
he didn't get out so there is no reason
to believe that he would be committing
ourselves that night on the first day he
was discharged bring up the bring up the
thing about the five children at the
bottom of that that overlay you had
about the five children at the bottom of
that there's something i want to read
here what i can i can't get close enough
to read it
considering that evidence no no he was
sentenced to prison for roughly 15 years
and authorities believed at the time his
risk to receive his risk to recidivate
being a great concern to the community
okay
you think he was going to get out and do
it again
the parole board was just like well
let's roll the dice i don't know
when you think of how many times they
denied morgan freeman did rosenbaum go
like so
you can find me guilty of child rape you
think i'll do it again
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm like i'll let
you free let him go yeah i mean what do
you do this arizona that it was in is
that yeah arizona
i think that 15 years
should have been extended to always yeah
forever yeah i think years to slow the
spread of rose and bomb yeah i i
you know make up for that they said
here the records included an interview
with rosenbaum in which he said his
stepfather sexually abused him and his
brother on an almost daily basis when he
was a preteen awesome it's like they're
trying to give them like a pass well it
sucks sucks obviously that sucks and he
still should uh you know but then
right choices right when you do it to
somebody else that kind of goes out the
window and sadly that does happen a lot
is it's like a
virus yeah
you know what though it doesn't always
happen
there are lots of people who are
sexually abused as kids and most of them
do not sexually abuse kids to be clear
most of them do not sexually abuse kids
now a lot of them end up having
relational issues but the vast majority
of people who are sexually abused as
kids of course they have trauma to deal
with they do not become child rapists
themselves so it is not an excuse
absolutely it's not well looking
you can't go sorry i just have to be
careful cause i don't want this
unnamed energy company to get mad like
oh no he's giving us free press right
blue donkey uh
so
nice job i was trying to think of a
quicker one
it gives you fins
[Laughter]
i feel like arizona was like ah we'll
release him but here's the only
condition
you've got to go to kenosha yeah he's
like stay here come on just let me stop
he tried to burn down the prison by
lighting his poop on fire and it's like
it doesn't work like that i just said
this guy's not kind of a pedophile if he
should have been to catch a predator
he's not the guy who would like show up
in dockers with some quiznos he's the
kind of guy who would show up naked
doing a dick helicopter like let's go
yeah with a chain yeah with a chain
uh-oh looks like they're coming back in
okay let's see how this goes oh thank
god it's hard to tell on cnn you can't
tell this is live this is live yeah this
is live what does that guy have behind
him it looks like a bunch of old audio
cassette tapes
which one
the judge it's uh those are books
[Laughter]
is that product placement he's still
eating oh he's just finishing gotta
finish that asian food
you know thai food no no no not to be by
the way this place is authentic they
bring it to you uh they have it brought
to you by ladyboys ah it's fresh john
cena is here to tell you thailand is not
real it's not a place it's not what it
was taiwan taiwan but
we don't want to get too off in the
weeds on geopolitics it's because i
don't read the audio tapes next to him i
feel like he's uh eating the cookies he
ordered the other day you remember
looking at the oh yeah yeah oh yeah
looking at the snake i ate a four
fortune cookie from that asian food you
know what i like to have let's open it
he's innocent wow that's one
whoa hold on we'll open another one uh
not guilty whoa yeah let's go for three
oh no wait defense this is the verdict
you guys already you have to let you're
supposed to listen to closing statements
but i like that you have to you like to
have a laugh did you how did you bake
these so fast
uh your honor uh we actually have a note
from the jury here let me read it to you
uh this is a complete waste of time okay
yeah no we agreed
seems like that's about wrapped up what
do you guys want for lunch there kfc i
know one of you does how about india oh
[Laughter]
because he's racist judge am i right now
we're making fun of the judge racist
judge he this is something a racist
judge would say that he said the asian
thing he said asian food oh my god i
know he's in germany
and that
distract you too much from uh the
presentation here no but their full
hearts will i had been and brain talking
about the murder of joseph how is blue
on blue and as you all right guys
just so you know we're watching this
again hey you know what let's listen to
him a little bit and if we get booted
from youtube okay then you guys can go
to rumble or mug club because we've been
doing this long enough so i want to hear
what he has to say because it's such
[ __ ]
so uh and comment below your thoughts on
how this is going thus far is this guy
trying to throw it testified that he was
i don't know it's a line of fire
behind joseph rosenbaum as the defendant
fires four rounds with his ar-15 which
is loaded with full metal jacket and oh
ammunition in a little bit uh but you've
heard testimony show them again that you
know nothing about ammunition right of
going through body armor
that's capable of going to a squad car
it is designed to go through the target
and continue flying on for up to 550
yards
did it richard mcginnis testified that
when those shots went off he thought he
had been hit
he's sorry
that's not what it's designed for no
it's not what it's designed to do that's
insane it's very cheap i think most
people yeah it's like it's not designed
to go 500 yards past the target
our armor piercing rounds are different
from full metal jackets full metal
jackets
hollow points are designed to try and
expand and disperse energy into the
target more right full metal jackets are
kind of the default with a lot of
riflings i mean i guess you could say
lead bullets just to be clear but that's
actually as a general rule i bet if
someone could bring this up right now
the top selling ar-15 like whether it's
223 or 556 ammunition
by volume it'll all just be full metal
jacket because that's cheap range ammo
it's far less expensive and it's far
less finicky and a gun it's what it's
basically what they used to call anyway
ball ammo sometimes it's referred to you
know it just means it's a basic bullet
it's sort of wartime as well yeah nato
doesn't a lot nato requires fullmetal
yeah that's what i thought yeah
joseph rosenbaum
and has his own video shows when he
first gets there he finds mr rosenbaum's
body face down disappointedly finds kyle
rittenhouse fully clothed
[Laughter]
and kills himself
oh come on now oh god people are going
to say we're being uh insensitive but uh
no i'm being perfectly sensitive that's
as sensitive as he deserves
he ain't moving
i feel bad for the guy because he didn't
know at the time that this guy was a
child rapist
down
i mean that's just sort of the default
position for rosenbaum yeah he's not a
big belt guy
[Music]
trying to get sympathy from the jury
i'm telling you he's so pale i would
have thought he was a ghost
i think rittenhouse might have thought
he was being haunted
a mess
what an absolute mess but you know what
guess what
you know who's responsible for this mess
is absolutely 100
democrats in charge of every major city
where this happened where they they not
only started with rhetoric of defunding
the police they told the police to stand
down the media vilified the police they
enabled and they they emboldened these
people saying hey these are mostly
peaceful protests guess what if you say
hey we're not only not going to defund
the police we're going to we're going to
we're going to juice them up we're going
to beef up their abilities right now to
make sure that they squash any riots
that even might start and by the way
we're going to harsher sentencing for
anyone who's out there after curfew
still rioting if they did that and the
media said these are not peaceful
protests americans need to stop guess
what they wouldn't have been so
emboldened to create that quagmire there
are several steps along the way where
you could have de-escalated this [ __ ]
instead kamala harris was saying they
should continue this is the new normal
or remember this is jacob blake police
officers shoot unarmed black man now
they shot a guy who was violating his
restraining order against the wife he
raped trying to kidnap his kids yeah the
but the headline was police shoot an
unarmed black man seven times in the
back he wasn't even unarmed he had a
knife you know he's trying what just
happened
this is exhibit number 12.
oh that's rosenbaum raping a kid sorry
yeah sorry 13. that's really more of a
sex tape
so there's just like six shots
so this you know what i remember i said
his closing arguments are just going to
be him going rogue that's what he's
doing you're just like look somebody
died here here look at this footage
somebody else dies isn't that bad
doesn't that upset you not guilty
[Music]
hey do you know who i bet you do you
know what do you know who i bet you
someone's yelling he pulled a gun i'm
not watching him pulling kyle said while
he's running away that he pulled the gun
but you're watching kyle saying that
kyle that's kyle running away after
saying he pulled the gun but he heard
the gunshot if kyle's referring to
zaminski pulling a gun on him yes then
yes yes
he did pull a gun
as he's running by the way it doesn't
matter
if he did or not he heard a gunshot
turned around there was the ghost
pedophile going
the defendant is lost enough save his
own skin instead of
going and trying to help the person well
you know what it's easy to say it's easy
to monday morning quarterback when you
don't have any skin it's more of a
more of a slimy ectoplasmic layer
well you also have other people running
using guns so obviously this wasn't a
shocking thing hold on listen he's
saying he's lying on the gate running
gage's thing mr gross crates asked the
defendant did you just shoot someone and
the defendant says something about the
police and then says i did not shoot
anyone
and this is similar to the lie that he
told jason lukowski at exactly that same
time as he passes mr lakowsky i'm afraid
this guy's going to be so slimy he's
going to convince them and that was
established because he's lying
he said i'm going to get the cops i
think it's worth it i'm going to the
police
he says something about the police i
don't know did he say something about
the police like did he say
the police or did he say i'm going to
the police yeah he's not playing the
video i'm one of the police like he's
gonna play the video yeah
nope
this is not the video
i'm going to go grab a little blue fin
if that's all right
towards danger did you get me one
running
or there's a full-size uh
movie stars this is exhibit number three
hey don't we have video can someone
bring it from the back there don't we
have video of kyle right now where he
did say i'm going to the cops didn't he
say hi that's what i'm trying to see are
they showing that i think they're
getting to that right now
what are you doing
you
who
what is he trying to say he's saying
let's see
is he trying to say that he's saying i
didn't shoot him saying i didn't shoot
anybody
it's hard to tell what his exact words
are i hear the word not
pretty clearly in there
what the [ __ ] do anything sorry but no
you've heard one word he lies too what
crowd what he's that's what he's saying
he even says like he said it there he's
like it's pretty hard to make it out uh
how about you quote him but the
convenient word that i need him to say
is the one i can hear is not what they
perceive to be an active shooter
someone who has just shot someone who is
still in possession of the gun
who is fleeing yes because axe is not
shooting anybody yes because active
shooters have their gun responsibly
aimed at the ground right with their
finger off of the trigger on the trigger
guard and tell people i am going to get
the police who are actively pursuing
them
no one let's be clear here guys
no one there was shot
who wasn't in the current act of
assaulting and that's important just to
be clear let me just be really clear
about this this is different from people
who attack cal written house no no not
only that
no one who was shot by kyle rittenhouse
was involved in anything other than
currently attacking him while they were
shot meaning
even if someone
attacked him and then left he didn't
shoot them meaning only wow rosenbaum
was reaching out saying fu reaching for
his gun did he get shot only wow the guy
was stomp kicking him or hitting him
with the skateboard did he shoot them
only wow crow scruts was approaching him
and aiming his gun at his head it's not
even like you could argue that it was
revenge shooting these were all in the
moment currently being attacked because
there were other people who made threats
and who ran up on him as you can see in
the security camera footage and he never
shot them only people who were involved
the second they were shot
with an attack on kyle rittenhouse it
doesn't get any clearer period ever if
he doesn't have the right to defend
himself women you don't have the right
to defend yourself when you're being
raped in your own home just to be clear
look at what he's saying down here
defending could have called 9-1-1 yelled
out fired warning shots dropped the gun
raised his hands he's saying that the
defendant could have in that moment when
the crowd is yelling get him when the
crowd is running after him when the
threat still exists from zaminski the
guy's friend thinking maybe this guy
figures out i shot his buddy i could
have dropped the gun i could have fired
a warning shot oh so fire a warning shot
so the crowd's not going to think you're
a threat if you fire a warning shot he's
saying that that crowd was justified
because he lied
himself by the way being chased by
people and you will say whatever you
need to do to get away from a mob
hunting this also just shows you how the
left fundamentally is uh completely
uninformed anyone here anyone here out
there anyone ever been to a uh firearm
safety training course yep how often do
they tell you to shoot into the air no
never
never take your gun out unless you are
prepared to use it never aim it anything
that you aren't willing to destroy so
unless you have some mastermind plan to
destroy the moon
you aim at the pedophile square in front
of you well steven it is a full metal
jacket ar-15 assault rifle it could
probably hit the moon boy a full metal
jacket i mean it could go a long
distance it could go through the moon
and hit mars full metal jacket many
nukes as they're known on the streets
awesome yeah cheapest rounds you could
possibly get that's the cheapest rounds
available tries to kick the defendant in
the face
anthony huber comes back and tries to
grab the gun actually does grab the
defendant's gun and tries to pull it
away because he's trying to disarm an
active shooter it's not an active
shooter and gage gross kreitz comes
running in stops with his hands up in
the air
until he sees and hears the defendant
adjusting his weapon as if preparing to
fry it fire again
and then what does gage gross croix do
notice that everything he says can't be
proven
right to try and disarm no no no no hey
bring up that picture oh he had a phone
in one hand and a gun aimed at cal
written out his head in the other can we
can bring up how was he going to
disarm kyle rittenhouse
testify about that he was trying to tape
a snuff film
look at that
that he was not prepared to make at that
point in time
he is not the type of person
who is just willing to take someone's
life then what was he doing
unlike the difference tell me who took
two lives
then why would you point at somebody's
head very easily
there is a video exhibit i don't care
what he says is the bg on the scene
video which traces this entire
incident which we call the second event
this is going to show you kyle defending
himself yet again mr groskroitz and the
other individuals who are trying to stop
an active shooter he's not an english
can we define that
can we please stick with definitions
possible
yeah i mean i don't it depends if
they're trying to say someone who had
shot somebody and isn't already disarmed
who hasn't shot anybody else said he's
running to the cops can we at least
argue that this is not an active shooter
i don't i don't understand the word it's
more of an active defender really
somebody tries to come up and hit him in
the back of the head yeah that person
didn't get shot no anthony hubert comes
in with a skateboard
he shouldn't boom
gets hit down stomped
hitting him skateboard gun away
hubert comes in this that's the guy with
the gun right there see that guy backing
away with his hands up he doesn't get
shot no you know why in just a few
seconds kyle wasn't being attacked by
him the first guy who tries to tackle
him to the ground and then runs off
doesn't get shot right
my point is only the people who were
currently attacking him were shot even
people who tried to get a jab in and
then ran weren't shot
no regard for life
only cares about himself uh and not
dying
you're saying he can't defend his life
this guy is such a piece of [ __ ]
i'm sorry nowhere only cares about
himself really really only cares about
himself mr uh assistant to the d.a who's
related to the mayor
really
only cares about himself didn't uh gross
crips have some charges dropped only
several days before the trial really
only cares about himself raping five
kids rosenbaum really only cares about
himself even but your argument has been
that he's not a qualified emt even
though he was there providing medical
assistance you argued that he shouldn't
have been yeah he was a lifeguard but
you argue that he wasn't currently a
lifeguard in that season in kenosha
you're saying he only cared about
himself he was a lifeguard and he
provided medical assistance in addition
to putting out fires you argued why did
he put down the fire extinguisher why
did he have the fire extinguisher only
cared about himself
why did he have sponges and buckets
earlier
when he was cleaning up graffiti
why was he seen on camera putting out
multiple fires before he ever shot
anybody and he only ever shot anybody
who was currently involved in a violent
attack against his person period there
were even people who threw [ __ ] at him
there were people who tried to tackle
him then ran off there were people right
there in that moment with their hands up
he didn't shoot them he only attacked
people who were violently attacking his
person then at that moment period but he
only cares about himself finger
hey how many fires did rosenbaum put out
broken it down gage frames huber and i
want to take you through jump kick guy
hey how many pieces of graffiti do they
clean up
hey
how much medical attention do they
actually provide oh your argument again
this is the standard for conservatives
right the standard for anyone who is not
seen as part of the left-wing mob is you
better be a 100 certified emt or we are
going to call you a fraud
you better be uh absolutely 100 percent
qualified uh uh to be cleaning up
graffiti and kenosha we don't
necessarily know how that happens
otherwise we're going to say that you
have no bed and you uh brought guns
across state lines hey you better be a
firefighter or we're going to blame you
for having a fire extinguisher and then
we're going to blame you when you put
the fire extinguisher down to use your
rifle to protect yourself
where are the standards for any of the
other people what was he doing there
what were you doing there at least we
could say let's say that you said he
wanted trouble
yeah he he was looking for trouble lay
low for a day and a half
clean up some graffiti put out some
fires bring a medic kit
be on camera so it's well documented
that you're there trying to help people
and then you find yourself in a melee
right leg
that was he's looking for trouble okay
was rosenbaum looking for trouble left
the asylum left the institution
and immediately went there
was gross crits looking for trouble a
guy who had no who
was he illegally carrying a firearm not
to mention illegally using it by aiming
it at someone who didn't attack him at
all
what was humor doing there were any of
them providing any sort of civil servant
now we know that they were lighting
fires we know they were bombing out
buildings and we know that they were
attacking a 17 year old kid
to say that kyle right now cares about
no one but himself it's just it's just
it's
he really is trying to go the slimy
lawyer route and own it right now
that the defendant is getting ready to
fire again
[Music]
by the way i've rewatched this this clip
but i don't see kyle
uh backing or anything no i don't see
him clear a malfunction or re-rack at
all
so i think all he was doing remember
when we first do it we're doing the
challenge by the way it looks like he
aimed it down away from him when his
hands were up and then aimed at that
doesn't look like he clears anything
look at this guy right over here to the
right that's what we said a year ago
holding a stick a very large stick in
his hands kyle can see that guy
obviously he's not pointing his gun at
him and none of these frames he's
his right hand with his glock pistol
pointed at the defendant
but he just said on good morning america
and cnn that he didn't point it at his
defender defenders
of course he didn't he never ever ever
ever would do that
he looks like he's
backing away kyle sees no he has a gun
in his hand you can see mr gross kreutz
is actually backing up yep with his
right leg okay yeah
back frame by frame right here
until this is frame 444.
you can see his right foot is
on the ground but it's starting to move
kyle's going to move forward kyle's gun
is down the frame is 447.
this is someone who is about to retreat
no that is something no
but then what happened what does he
actually do he's leaning forward backing
away and now
he's testified he sees the defendant
start to manipulate that gun in such a
way that it makes mr gross croits feel
like he's about to be shot oh come on
then does he take action [ __ ] what
action does mr gross kreutz take what
are you talking about does he hold that
gun with bullets the gun is still aimed
down the gun is still aimed down right
now
and gross bridge it's on his way back in
does he even take the gun with one hand
and point it yes no he does yes
whoa why
see him start to lunge in with his left
arm forward
never the gun is not in this hand
because this is his right hand it is
though he's lunging forward reaching for
the defendant
probably reaching for the gun
probably trying to block i think that he
was retweeting you can't see now where's
the right take a step with his right leg
across and the gun is still down keep in
mind the gun is still down not directly
towards the defendant now he's being
crossed the defendant's body he's
wheeling up now he brings the gun up
because you can see the most swiping
away at that gun with his left arm
he has bladed his body in such a ways to
try and present as minimal of a target
as possible which is probably what saves
his life
his right leg is about to hit the ground
here the gun the ar-15 is pointing left
for the rest of his life yeah he already
is a lefty two maybe three feet away
he's trying to shield himself and you
put your ear spreaders in with
and as we approach frame 500 here
the gun goes off
but at no point in this process talk
about the right hand is mr grosskroyd's
pointing his gun at the defender
frame 499.
the gun is just fired
frame 500 you see the puff of smoke
501 the bullet has hit mr gross kreutz's
right bicep severing it
with the gun in the hand again i'm going
to pull this out after this yeah can we
bring it up again yeah look right there
there's also i think we have a better
picture we have a video that we can
bring up 504 you can see why would this
even be relevant when he had said on the
stand that he pointed the gun as well
yeah but he changed his mind there are
many many videos guys just send me
whatever the best clip whatever it is
that we can show that shows uh we've
already shown this many times that he
was obviously aiming his gun at him not
only that mr gross just had his right
bicep severed
yeah voluntary action
well no one's saying it was voluntary to
get his bicep severed it's voluntary
now watch frame five he's gonna be
halfway watch his right hand
503
504
505. first off
admitted that he aimed his gun at him
and it's on camera that he aimed his gun
at him and isn't it interesting that he
just tried he constantly contradicts his
own arguments because he's throwing this
is what he's doing right now throwing
everything at the wall that he can he's
going look it's very clear gross crouch
was retreating
see until he uh heard which of course we
never could hear or see in any footage
available that it seemed like uh kyle
was uh re-racking his weapon and uh only
then did he approach without a gun in
his hand and once he was shot in the
bicep a gun magically appeared in his
hand and he couldn't let it go yeah he's
trying to build the case that he was
blocking
the gun while turning around and just
happened to have a weapon so he was
trying to get away and block the bullet
the problem is is the video has him
facing the completely other way yes
here's the picture we have when he's got
the gun
in his hand as he's running up to him
yeah he's running up to him the gun is
and then uh yes when he when he's
shooting the skateboard guy right so
he's got the gun there right
but do we have the other picture where
uh well the one that you just showed me
was blurry but maybe it's just because
i'm thinking of when it's the actual
clip but what's the highest res picture
we have of of gage aiming his gun at
kyle
that makes you a threat i can kill you
except for kyle rittenhouse i can do it
all night long
he didn't name his gun at anyone who
wasn't actively trying to kill him
everyone else
and everyone else has a right to defend
themselves also not just the defendant
well then it's a matter of who defended
themselves better yeah
if you want to make that argument or who
started it to where the other one had to
defend themselves
but he thought he was an active shooter
even though he said he wasn't
and said he was going to the cops
so you're saying that gage is a white
vigilante
[ __ ]
caught me there boy i guess this is kind
of what happens when your case is paper
thin
uh you know
i'm saying he's a child there you go not
guilty
seem to work for rosenbaum he's been
venerated so it's true
15 years that's all he did so do you
guys understand this right now what the
left wants you to understand is you
would be better off
molesting and anally raping
five children
then you would be defending yourself
from rioters and looters do you hear
that clearly
kyle rittenhouse would get more time in
prison than joseph rosenbaum
who anally raped violently a kid against
his will a nine or 11 year old and then
five kids at least molested them
well the next time the minority of
people are burning down an area because
it's not that's the thing is this isn't
the majority of people it's just enough
people that are angry to damage a place
right so the the minority side of people
that are burning down an area you're not
going to get people out there that want
to help because this is the result of it
right yeah well you don't you can't the
police can't help yeah
well that did not look good no it didn't
yeah
looks kind of like when you go to
disneyland and have the big turkey legs
yes
yeah but you've taken a couple bites out
of it and then it still has some of like
the small bones yeah and you're like i
don't want yeah i don't want anymore
i think my eyes were bigger than my
stomach
who wants funnel cake
and then you realize that looks like a
wrestler's ear
oh
no those ever been in montreal the
beaver tails love oh
they add like nutella and bananas
attention to it oh so they make it
better yeah they're making that certain
himself
to other people
let's flip it
it was a show and i don't know if he was
a superhero but he was he was a powerful
it killed two people
little beaver to mr gross koitz's arm
boy that bluefin energy drink is just
awful i never drink that stuff it is
just it's just not good oh no it's just
for waking you up kurt not for i like
the movie star ones those taste pretty
good there's a couple of good flavored
movie stars yeah the defendant's
position at that couple there are a
couple decent uh goblins energy drinks
and gentlemen there's also jock tar
oh yes
which is not too bad if you even the
sugar free in the jock tower is pretty
good really yeah
ordinary
person
and you will put yourself in the
defendant's shoes that night
i submit to you
that at the time of those shootings a
reasonable person in the defendant's
shoes would have known
that he had provoked joseph rosenbaum
yeah by pointing his gun by being
underage that the defendant had put
someone else at risk more rounds
he's going for provocation i hate
that is reasonable a lot of sleazy
it is also reasonable
to understand that at that point gage
gross courts had just witnessed all of
this he had heard the defendant had shot
someone
he'd heard the defendant lie the only
excuse for a man
haircut like that is if the judge
swirled him on break
[Laughter]
the defendant kill anthony hubert you're
in your 50s sir yeah
i preached in 98. yes his life was in
big fan of tin tin
and he was pretty incredible
because the defendant shot him too
so when you consider what's reasonable
in this case consider that do you think
i look like nicolas
tell me
tell me i do i just look like his
brother because i'd take that too but
yes i wouldn't be as happy about it i'd
be a nerdy lache
the edible just sent me a video that um
shows that when when rosenbaum comes up
on ridden house he's clearly not putting
the gun and it's a pretty clear video it
goes by pretty fast we can show that
rosenbaum comes up on random wait
yeah he takes off
oh oh is that because that's where
they're trying to say that he pointed a
gun at rosenbaum i think so yeah yeah no
he doesn't point a gun yeah it's very
clear
it is unbelievably clear all right look
i think it's probably as good a time as
any now that gerald is back let's give a
couple quick clothing thoughts and then
we're going to go to uh mug club only
because i'm tired and i can't do this
the whole time we don't really need to
listen to the defense's statements
because it's just going to be
[Laughter]
just uh do with the information what you
will ladies and gentlemen of the jury
that guy he did a whole lot of lion and
uh we have video uh of all of it so yeah
uh i rest my case okay there you go and
that guy just says [ __ ] that's it
pretty much if he just like blares that
to the speakers oh my chest is hurting
too i'm bending over here uh after this
after the surgery sometimes my old rib
cage you'll titanium
um i get it
no you don't no i don't i feel exactly
what you get it at all
but uh where are you gonna be uh uh this
weekend naples naples florida at off the
hook comedy club monday all right monday
friday and saturday naples florida hey
by the way we are going to be covering
the verdict is it supposed to be
tomorrow their token island are they
saying as early as tomorrow as early as
tomorrow yeah so we don't know when it
will be so look uh follow me on on
instagram on twitter on rumble mug club
because we don't know when if in other
words revert comes in or they're saying
that a verdict will come in our show may
be delayed because we want to cover that
live
uh
we need to have some streamers and
balloons and stuff ready well yeah for
when he's found not guilty yeah
um let's get on a good cake
okay get it from the erotic bakery only
sever it
yes well they they actually make those
now yeah yeah yeah they're called it's
called it's called i want that cake
rosenbomb it's a genderless gender party
yeah so um
before we go we're gonna continue
watching this here on mug club is uh
gosh i hope this is really clear to
everyone out there we're going to start
chatting with more of you here on my
club where we're not really beholden to
youtube's rules this is unbelievable
your right to self-defense is on trial
but p people saying what would you you
want the kind of america where people
just go in
to protect their streets
yeah yes yes i do wait is my choice
america that burns like we saw that
summer and of course you'll see probably
before midterms or an america where you
have responsible gun owners stopping the
looters rioters and by the way i don't
think that it should have to get to the
point where someone has a gun at your
head point blank for you to have the
right to defend yourself does anyone out
there believe that does anyone out there
believe anyone including if you're not a
conservative do you really believe that
you only have the right to defend
yourself or your family when someone has
a gun pointed at your head if you're
being raped by someone who just has a
chain a knife or might be 80 120 pounds
heavier than you what if you're a kid
and it's a serial pedophile who breaks
into the house when your parents are
gone do you have the right to protect
your your own life and home do you
really believe this is really what it
comes down to what they are arguing is
you shouldn't ever have the right to use
lethal force not only not to protect
property not only not to protect your
home and your livelihood not only not to
protect against people destroying
property but who are also committing
violent felonies with weapons not only
should you not be able to use lethal
force to protect your life if someone is
threatening it if they don't have a
firearm you should only be allowed to
protect yourself if someone has a gun
and it is already aimed at you and the
irony of it is
we have exactly that here and they're
still bitching about it all right
youtube we don't really care you can
piss off let's continue this on mug club
foreign